Ladies and gentlemen of the class of 21. Jahrhundert, if I could offer you only one tip for the future, the SSD would be it. A long-term benefits of SSDs have been proved by scientists, whereas the rest of my advice has no basis more reliable than my own meandering experience.
Wenn man Fanboy sein will, eigentlich generell, bleibt eigentlich nur Apple.
Ich verstehe so langsam, warum sich dieser Ebook-Markt nicht entwickelt, weil das totale Scheiße ist bisher.
Alles was Apple macht, ist irgendwie heilig.
Ich bin zu naiv und der Rest ist eigentlich ganz okay.
Bisschen kritischer bei manchen Sachen könnte man schon sein.
Es ist alles so gekommen, wie ich das schon immer gesagt.
Der macht den Mega-Apple-Fanboy-Podcast so. Wenn wir den jetzt verärgern, dann lässert er wieder zwei Stunden lang in seiner Sendung ab. Unsere Mitarbeiter hören diese Sendung, sind danach eine Woche schlecht drauf und unsere Produkte leiden. Wir müssen mal wieder über Macs reden.
Wir wollen ja hier mehr über Macs reden.
Wir sollten mal wieder mehr über Macs reden. Super. Osama bin Laden hat nämlich sein iPhone benutzt. Da hatten sie ihn. Da hatten sie ihn.
Meinst du Osama bin Laden hat ein weißes iPhone gehabt?
Der hat ja auch mal so weißes Tuch an und so.
Klar.
Hoben sie die Nummer neben ihrer Landesflagge an. Wenn wir die beiden jetzt lassen, endet das wieder böse.
Ich hör's schon.
So sehr ich das jetzt sehe, dass das iOS mit seinen vielen guten und vielleicht auch weniger guten neuen Erfindungen zurück auf den Mac kommt.
So wenig sehe ich, dass wir dieses Prinzip des Full-Blown-Macintosh, der alles kann, anytime soon einbüßen werden. Diese Terminals werden uns erhalten bleiben.
Noch eine Weile.
So lange wie IBM.
Gut, und damit schließen wir dieses Video.
Ich glaube, es hätte schlimmer kommen können. Ich weiß jetzt nicht.
So, und jetzt?
Das heißt ja nicht umsonst Bumzak, return.
Hier ist Moba Max. Wir begrüßen alle unsere Hörer da draußen. Hier gibt es keine Abwechslung bei diesem Podcast.
Neues Intro.
Naja, alles neu macht der Juni.
Ich wollte gerade vorschlagen, die Reihenfolge zu ändern, damit man das auf das previous Lied danach direkt eingehen kann, ohne nochmal den Song dazwischen zu haben.
Ähm, wir können an allem arbeiten. Das ist ja alles Kunst, ne?
Das ist mir auch aber schon aufgefallen, Max. Sehr richtig, ja. I second that opinion. Das umzudrehen, also erst den Bumzak, return und dann das...
Aber so ist das nicht bei Lost.
Ja, bei Lost ist...
Lost ist doch eh vorbei.
Lost ist vorbei.
Denis nickt auch.
Vor allen Dingen war Lost ja auch totaler Quatsch. Also das ist ja nicht Realität.
Was? Lost ist doch kein Quatsch.
Ja, das, also...
Wieso?
Also bei Lost waren eigentlich ähnliche Dinge genauso wie im Apple-Universum unterwegs. Ja, da gab's so Höhlen, die so glühten und die ganze Zeit tauchten irgendwelche mystischen Priester auf und immer, wenn alle mit Spannung auf den bestimmten Moment hingefiebert haben, puff, war auf einmal alles ganz anders, als man gedacht hat.
Meinst du, das war ein riesiges Reality-Disortion-Field?
Also da würde ich zustimmen, aber das war ja erst in der fünften Staffel, wo dann das religiöse Element hinzukam. Davor war das ja alles so eher wie bei Myst.
Tja, und in welcher Staffel sind wir?
Hand hoch, wer hat von euch Myst gespielt?
Ich hab ein bisschen darin rumgeklickt.
Toll, ich weiß, dass es in Hypercard geschrieben war.
Ernsthaft?
Ich glaube auch, ja. Und ich fand ja Lost, das war so am Anfang, das hat mich total gekickt, weil es so war wie Myst.
Ich hab das eine Staffel geguckt, weil alle so oh, Lost, musst du gucken, ist total klebrig, aber muss man gucken und...
Ja, es gibt solche und solche. Bei mir war das so, ich hab das sehr spät gesehen und dann hab ich es mit meiner Freundin, haben wir 5 Staffeln in 14 Tagen geschaut.
Ja, also das ist das Übliche, was ich so kenne.
Ich sag erst mal Hallo und guten Tag und willkommen bei Mobile-Max-Ausgabe Nr. 66, hier wo die Nerds sprechen, die auch Freundinnen haben. Und von daher sind wir natürlich ausgesprochen privilegiert, darüber zu glaskugeln, was denn so kommt.
Deswegen ist Denis heute auch nicht da. Ja, Denis hat heute seinen Ehrentag.
Genau.
Wollen wir mal singen?
Da darf er dann irgendwie... Wollen wir mal singen?
Was singen wir denn?
Achso, wir müssen irgendwas geben. Wir dürfen nicht Happy Birthday rollen, da müssen wir Gebühren abdrücken, ne?
Stimmt.
Wir... Ach, der kriegt nächste Mal so eine kleine Wachskerze auf seiner Pizza. Oder 41.
Okay, genug Anteilnahme.
Hat er nächstes Jahr das magische Jahr? Na ja, 42.
Jetzt habt er ja auch für dich alles aufgetlaut.
Nee, gerade hat die ja...
Was hat die gerade Hucke erzählt?
Die glauben ja wohl nicht, was im Internet gesagt wird, ne? Man sieht ja auf den Bildern ganz deutlich, dass Denis noch knack junger...
Gott ist.
36 ist.
Aber gegrüßt bist du uns, Denis.
Denis hat uns ja auch eine Grußbotschaft mitgegeben.
Ja, was denn?
Er hat ja... Also in den Kommentaren wurde sich ja letztens mal so ein bisschen auch beschwert. Also einige meinten ja Bitcoin-Thema super, andere meinten, was ist denn das für ein Scheiß? Und Denis meint jetzt auch, wir sollen alles zurücknehmen und das Gegenteil behaupten. Und in der nächsten Sendung, wo er wieder da ist, stellt er alles richtig.
Was habt ihr denn behauptet?
Na, wir haben ja versucht, das so zu erklären, aber da wussten wir ja gerade, da haben wir ja gerade selber erst ein paar Stunden davor uns das alles mal ein bisschen angelesen.
Aber dann erst mal eine halbe Stunde im Podcast darüber braggen, so ist das.
Und jetzt ist Denis aber selber voll im Bitcoin-Business und wird dann nächstes Mal wahrscheinlich...
Denis ist eine Bank.
Falls er überhaupt noch kommt, falls er so oft nötig hat. Wird er mit seinem Hubschrauber direkt...
Ja, ob er mit uns überhaupt noch redet, wenn er eine Bank ist. Bankbänker sind ja ein bisschen anders so, ne?
Aber Denis ist auch nicht so der Otto-Normal-Bänker.
Da hat er ja so zwei iPad 2 um den Hals hängen oder so.
Ja, der Themengabentisch ist reich gedeckt. Ich bin immer wieder erstaunt, wenn man zwei Wochen wartet, was sich dann doch wieder alles ergibt. Selbst wenn man versucht, die News... Wie soll ich sagen?
Diese Gerücht-News zu ignorieren.
Bleibt dann trotzdem, wenn man noch so einiges. Wir haben viel gesammelt, aber wir haben nichts sortiert. Deswegen bin ich jetzt gerade ein bisschen schwierig. Worauf habt ihr denn Lust? Wollen wir uns so mit der Außenwelt beschäftigen oder bleiben wir in unserem Apple, in unserem heimähnlichen Apple-Reich? Apple-Reich.
Apple-Reich.
Vielleicht könnten wir auch mal Apple-Woll trinken.
Das könnten die Zuhörer allerdings schon mal bewerkstelligen, finde ich ja auch. Ich sehe hier immer die großen Pakete, die hier für Not Safe for Work und so ankommen. Und hier bei Mobile Max, da ist ja mal lange nichts gekommen. Oder schickst du das wieder deinen Kindern?
Ich muss auch jetzt gerade mal überlegen, aber ich glaube, da ist jetzt gerade nichts dabei.
Wir dürfen übrigens explizit Not Safe for Work Schokolade essen.
Genau, das ist erlaubt.
Da ist so viel gekommen.
Die mochte Holgi nicht, oder was?
Ne, wir sind noch nicht zu einer neuen Sendung gekommen und es wurde zwischenzeitlich solche Tonnenweise an Obermengen und ich bin ja eigentlich überhaupt keinen Schokoladen-in-Podcast-Freund. Aber naja, wenn es einem dann so überkommt, dann kann man das ja auch mal machen. Jetzt sind wir, sagen wir mal, mit der Themenauswahl noch kein Stück näher gekommen, ne?
Ne, wir haben Single-Series.
Also wir haben natürlich die WWDC. Wir machen jetzt sozusagen so ein bisschen so ein Preview, ne? Das ist auch mal was schönes. Nach dem Rückblick machen wir den Preview.
Wollen wir erzählen, was kommt?
Genau, später bei Overwax.
Oh na, da hatte ich mir aber schon mehr erwartet.
Das hat mich wirklich total enttäuscht.
Aber da war ich wirklich überrascht.
Du meinst, dass sie vorneweg gesagt haben?
Oh ja, ja, ja.
Dass sie vorneweg gesagt haben?
Und alles in weiß.
Aber ausgerechnet an Dave verkaufen?
Aber wir können ja mal so die Themen erst mal aufgreifen, die wir so das letzte Mal schon so ein bisschen gekratzt haben. Und gehen wir mal ganz sanft rein. Ich könnte zum Beispiel mal... Ich hatte ja diese Geschichte mit Firewire 800-Gehäuse und SSD am iMac ranbammeln. Und wo, ehre wem ehre gebührt, mich der Timo von Bits und so draufgebracht hat, das hab ich dann mal selber gemacht. Ich hab dann mir auch die besprochene 120GB-Variante gekauft, gleich festgestellt, als ich da mal angefangen hab, rum zu installieren, dass mir das hinten und vorne nicht reicht. Und bin dann gleich auf die 300GB-Variante gegangen. War ein sehr schickes Gehäuse. Also abgesehen davon, dass es wahrscheinlich das Einzige ist, was es derzeit überhaupt zu irgendeinem brauchbaren Preis zu kaufen gibt, was Firewire 800 Ports bietet, ist es auch wirklich ein echt schickes Gehäuse. Ja, meine neue Liebe sind Klettstreifen. Und damit hab ich das einfach hinten an meinen Einwegfuß ran geballert.
Das heißt ja, hab ich kürzlich gelernt, Velcro.
Achso, hier steht sogar Velcro. Ich hab da vorhin gesagt, das hab ich irgendwo gelesen.
Genau, aber bei uns heißt das ja Klett, weil das ja auch nach der Klettpflanze erfunden wurde.
Das ist jetzt so ein bisschen Einweg-Erweiterung für Anfänger.
Ja, ich mein, das ist wirklich tod-einfach. Das ist jetzt wirklich überhaupt kein Megamodul.
So, niemand sagen, das Ding wär nicht erweiterbar. Einfach hinten mit Klettverschluss ne neue Festplatte dran kleben.
Ja, einfach, also man sieht die halt dann irgendwie nicht. Du kannst den Einweg nach wie vor so durch die Gegend tragen und so. Kannst auch mit dem Gummiband da ran streppen. Ich glaub, von der Idee, auf die Idee bin ich gekommen. Ich glaub, Helmi hat das auf Twitter irgendwie gepostet, dass er das so gemacht hat, ne super Idee. Und dann hatte ich gerade diese Klettstreifen. Wie auch immer, in der Konfiguration macht das Ding mal so lockere 81 Megabyte pro Sekunde, die es da so rüberwuppt, lesend und schreibend.
Das ist ja quasi Anschlag dann, ne, für Firewire Achtung.
Genau, das denke ich mal so das, was man da so rausholen kann. 800 Megabit, 81 Megabyte pro Sekunde, also da... Der holt einfach alles raus, was sich irgendwie über diesen Bus zu realisieren ließe. Wenn man es schneller haben will, muss man dann Thunderbolt anstreben.
Und hast du dir auch vergoldetes Firewire-Kabel geholt?
Klar und geweint.
Okay, und dann trotzdem nur 80?
Ja, das hat mich auch sehr enttäuscht.
Hättest du mal doch mal die Platin-Variante gekauft.
Ja, oder vielleicht kann man ja die Platten vorhin noch zum Papst schicken. Da passen die Bits hochkant durch.
Die flutschen ja besser, noch ein bisschen mit Vaseline einreiben.
Ja, okay, also dann...
Festplatten-Gleitmittel. Da müssen sie Festplatten-Gleitmittel auftragen.
Dann wird die Bits besser durch.
Ja genau, das kostet nur 30 Euro.
Und ist alles schnell jetzt. Ist jetzt wie neu geboren. Das Ableton, das schnippt und schnappt nur so.
Ja, also ich hab jetzt die Konfiguration noch nicht so super lange fertig. Das läuft jetzt seit... Hört ihr uns im Stream?
Wir müssen reden morgen, wenn ich wieder vor der Technik sitze.
Mac OS X Migration ist ja immer wieder so ein Thema. Also das war ja so das Ding. Und es dauert schon einen Tag. Also erst mal musst du da ein OS drauf installieren. Das braucht eine Weile mit Updates. Tralala, du bist ja auch gerade am installieren parallel. Dann musst du halt auch gut überlegen, gerade jetzt so bei der Migration, was ja sehr schön ist, bei dem Migration Assistant, dass du eben sagen kannst, ich will jetzt hier auch diese Homes übernehmen, aber eben nicht diese Unterordner und so, dass du so fein Granular aufklappen kannst. Das heißt, ich konnte da so meine fetten Brocken, also iTunes, Movies, Ordner und so ein paar andere Sachen, die da noch drin lagen, die habe ich dann eben auf der internen Platte belassen. Alles andere da weggekratzt. Eigentlich will ich lieber eine Konfiguration haben, wo ich wirklich wieder alles auf der SSD habe, was ich so als Running System brauche. Und die interne Festplatte des iMacs würde ich dann einfach als Time Machine Backup benutzen. Das fände ich eigentlich optimal. Weil das ist halt schnell und zuverlässig und lalala. Aber so habe ich es jetzt nicht. Aber dann habe ich wieder gemerkt, so, egal wie viel man da so migriert, irgendwas bleibt immer auf der Strecke. Was mir aufgefallen ist, was auf der Strecke blieb, trotz Migration Assistant, ist zum Beispiel meine wirklich extrem heilige Zuordnung, welche Programme, welche Dateitypen werden mit welchen Programmen geöffnet.
Die heilige Zuordnung.
Die heilige Zuordnung. Ja, das ist für mich so exzellentarisch wichtig, dass ich sicher weiß, welches Programm dein MP3 aufmacht, wenn ich das doppelt drücke. Ja, und es soll eben nicht der Default iTunes sein, weil das ist hell. Weil dann macht es den auf und kopiert es erstmal in seinen iTunes-Ordner und so einen Scheiß. Also, Apple hat ja wirklich die aber witzigsten Vorstellungen davon, wie so ein Default auszusehen hat.
Teilweise spielt es sogar ab. Und wie kann man die dann wieder herstellen, diese Datei zu ordnen? Ich weiß das ehrlich gesagt gar nicht.
Keine Ahnung, ich fang jetzt wieder an. Ja, für mich ist jetzt vor allem Audio-Dateien wichtig. Es ist jetzt nicht so mega viel, aber es ist halt so eine Sache, die sie vergessen haben irgendwie.
Ich dachte, das war eine Datei, die man nur rückwärtschneiden sollte.
Ich dachte, du hättest auch mal so ein Tool dafür gehabt. Wofür? Für diese Datei zu ordnen. Ach nee, das war für die Service-Menü.
Ja, es gibt dieses eine Tool, was du jetzt ansprichst, das heißt, ich vergess den Namen jedes Mal wieder. Und ist das überhaupt diese Migration überlebt? Ah ja, genau, das heißt RC-Default-Ups. Das kann ich sehr empfehlen. Das Uralt hat sich auch seit Ewigkeiten nicht geändert, liegt aber immer noch, Downloadable funktioniert frisch wie am ersten Tag. Selbst wer nichts ändern möchte, ist mal ein interessanter Einblick darüber, was es eigentlich alles so an Datei-identifizierenden Typenarten gibt in Mac OS 10. Oder sagen wir mal nicht Datei, sondern Daten-Identifizierung im weiteren Sinne. Also gibt es Default Ups, kannst du dann erstmal deine Default-Programme einstellen für der Webbrowser und so weiter, was du ja sonst nur innerhalb von Safari machen kannst. Was ist das Default-Programm für E-Mail etc.?
Oh, habe ich da gerade Postbox gesehen?
News, interessant, ja. News ist hier noch... Kein Mensch weiß, was News ist, aber... Oder bezieht sich das auf... Ne, das bezieht sich hier auf RSS.
Das ist News.
Das ist Newsnet.
Gut, das ist jetzt nicht so interessant. Dann auch diese ganzen Media. Wenn ich CD einwerfe, welches Programm wird gelongert, hast du alles an einem Punkt.
Mini-DVD-Device.
Menschenskinder, was es nicht alles gibt.
Und jetzt muss ich hier kurz mal ein Rescanning abwarten, was Gott sei Dank schnell geht. Dann kannst du auch zu jedem installierten Programm, wobei jetzt hier immer wieder Smart, die Programme auch alle wieder doppelt auftauchen, das ist auch so eine schöne Geschichte, auch so weil hier noch extern irgendwas ist.
Grafikkonverter.
Dann kannst du eben die ganzen Extensions, die von einer Applikation registriert sind, sehen und einzeln aktivieren und deaktivieren etc. Dann hast du die Liste aller registrierten URLs.
Also Protokollhändler?
Genau, der Protokollhändler, also alles, was vor dem Doppelpunkt steht. Da siehst du überhaupt erst mal, was alles in deinem System so installiert ist. So was weiß ich hier, so was wie Mac App Store Doppelpunkt.
Das ist ja noch relativ wahrscheinlich.
Message Doppelpunkt.
Das ist Mail? Eine Mail-Message ist damit gemeint.
Ach, dass man die direkt ansprechen kann.
Und alle Programme, die du installierst, so was weiß ich hier, so TomTom Home. Also alle benutzen das irgendwie. Oder so Twitter zum Beispiel, Twitter Doppelpunkt. Was ich zum Beispiel ganz gerne verwende und nur die original Twitter App kann mit dem Twitter Protokollschirm umgehen. Was der blöde ist, weil ich in meinem Adressbuch, wenn ich einen Twitter, das ist auch so ein klassisches Problem, wie notiere ich den Twitter-Namen eines Menschen, den ich kenne, im Adressbuch, so dass das sinnvoll ist?
Instant Messenger.
Wie macht ihr das? Also wo tragt ihr es ein? Und wie tragt ihr es ein?
Ich trage es gar nicht ein. Und mach das dann direkt über den Twitter?
Und du als Instant Messenger. Aber es ist ja... Ja, ich weiß. Was ich mache ist, ich trage es als URL ein, als Twitter-Doppelpunkt-Name. Mit Echo Phone geht das nicht so gut, aber mit Twitter-App zum Beispiel geht das wunderbar.
Und was macht der denn? Der geht dann auf die Profilseite quasi von dem...
Der macht dann, ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, wie die Twitter-App sich verhält, tut irgendwie das Richtige. Nee, es ist im Sinne von Nachricht an sowieso schreiben.
Ach, tatsächlich, direkt Nachricht.
Das ist ja das, was du in dem Moment dann auch willst. Naja, also das lohnt sich da auch mal durchzugehen. Dann hast du die ganzen Extensions im System, also die ganzen File-Namen, Extensions, wo du dann eben explizit sagen kannst, hier so...
Naja, aber das ist jetzt nur eine umgekehrte Zuordnung von einem Teil, der da bei Apps drinne stand.
Nee, das eine ist, was in den Apps registriert ist und was dann auch irgendwie enabled ist. Und das andere ist, was dann tatsächlich von dir gesetzt wird, welche Datei, wenn ich sie doppel klicke, was dann gestartet wird.
UTIs hab ich gar keinen, ich weiß nicht, was das sein könnte.
UTIs sind eigentlich Apples... Was heißt das nochmal gleich? Universal Type Identifier.
Oder Unique?
Unique Type Identifier.
Also diese umgedrehte URL, die sie sich irgendwann mal angewöhnt haben.
Gleich zum Anfang von Mobile Max heute gleich mal...
Der richtig langweilige Teil.
Noch anders, also es ist der Uniform Type Identifier. Ja gut, aber das ist sozusagen der Name, der im Wesentlichen umgedrehte URL ist in der Regel, aber auch nicht immer, der halt einen Dateityp klar macht. Du kannst halt im Dateisystem diese UTI explizit zuweisen und die override dann halt irgendwie alles andere. Dafür kannst du dann auch die Fault Applications machen. Ich war ja eigentlich vorhin das. Ich war bei dieser Migration. Ich finde das ist aber eine sehr wichtige Sache. Wenn ich migriere, dann ist das für meine tägliche User Experience so entscheidend, dass das korrekt gesetzt ist. Das möchte ich gerne, dass eine Migration das auch migriert.
Du hast also einen IMAC mit Migrationshintergrund.
Naja, wie auch immer.
RC-Default-Ups, schaut es euch mal an, ist mindestens interessant, wenn nicht sogar hilfreich. Vielleicht noch mal kurz zu dem Thema SSD. Ich hatte ja dann sozusagen auch gleich diesen Fall, dass ich eine SSD mit Daten drauf hatte, die ich dann gleich wieder zum Händler habe zurückgehen lassen. Und dann dieses klassische Problem, wie lösche ich meine SSD? Und einer der Gründe, warum ich mich für die Intel-SSDs entschieden hatte, ist ja, wie wir das ja auch diskutiert haben, dass da eben bei Default immer alles schon verschlüsselt ist. Und wenn man der Platte sagt, vergiss mal den Key und so, dann haben wir darüber geredet, wie geht denn das überhaupt? Und geht das über Firewall? Also wie es aussieht, geht es nur über SATA. Und es geht auch derzeit nur über ein Tool von Intel, das heißt Intel SSD Toolbox.
Was hier auf dieser CD mit dabei ist, wenn man sich die kauft?
Ah ja, interessant. Oder auch auf der Webseite.
Also bei mir war hier so eine...
Ach ja, so eine Mini-CD, mit der man sich dann erst mal sein MacBook kaputt macht. Sind das irgendwie nicht diese engen Partner von Apple? Oh, ich keine Ahnung. Und natürlich dieses Tool nur für Windows. Klar, weil warum sollte man auch auf dem Mac Daten löschen wollen? Ja, und dann habe ich die Platte aber einfach zu meinem Händler meines Vertrauens getragen, weil ich mir dachte, na ja, ich habe ja keinen Windows, aber PC-Händler und so hat das Problem nicht so sehr. Dann sage ich so, hier, lösch noch mal. Dann guckt er mich an und so, du, wir haben keine PCs mehr. Was? Ihr habt keine PCs? Verstehst du, PC-Händler, ja? Hat keine PC, also im Einsatz.
Also sie verkaufen welche.
Sie haben keine im Einsatz.
War das der Fuchs? Aber der hat auch mal PCs verkauft?
Der verkauft auch immer noch PCs. Der verkauft halt auch schon immer Macs. Und guckt mich halt genau mit diesem selben Blick an, mit dem ich ihn eigentlich angucken wollte. So dieses, du weißt schon, ich will das ja nicht installieren. Jetzt geht das bei PC-Händlern auch schon los.
Das ist krass, oder?
Auf jeden Fall Programm installiert, la la la, da gab es schon noch so.
Will Gates bei Microsoft rum? Hey, kann man meine SSD löschen?
Dafür gibt es Bootcamp. Der Name ist eigentlich wirklich treffend gewählt. Ja, das war meine Empfehlung. Und ich kann euch sagen, das ist eigentlich ein relativ günstiges Upgrade. Also wenn man jetzt nicht gleich einen neuen Mac kaufen will, dann kann man das halt so machen. Und wenn man halt mit weniger als 300GB ankommt, dann ist es auch nicht so teuer. Aber mit 120GB ging es bei mir einfach nicht. Das war einfach... ging nicht.
Ich hatte ja ein bisschen drauf gehofft, dass die nächsten MacBook Airs dann irgendwie eine 500er haben werden. In der Maximalausstattung.
Also wie gibt es schon neue MacBook Airs?
Die nächsten, die nächsten.
Na noch gibt es die natürlich nicht, aber die nächsten gibt es immer noch nie. Noch nicht so.
Ja, also ich habe mir jetzt ja auch eine SSD heute gekauft. Fürs Notebook, die gleiche, die Denis sich gekauft hat.
Du hast auch in deinem Notebook schon eine SSD drin.
Ja, aber ich habe jetzt von meinem neuen Arbeitgeber ein neues Notebook bekommen und die haben sich irgendwie angestellt und wollten mir keine SSD kaufen. Dann meinte ich zu dem Admin, ja kann ich mir dann selber eine kaufen? Dann meinte er, ja offiziell nicht, aber mach schon. Ja, und jetzt habe ich hier gerade installiert und musste es von optischem Medium installieren und es dauerte 33 Minuten. Das ist so...
Optisches Medium.
Ich weiß auch nicht, warum der ganze Scheiß nicht schon längst auf USB ausgeliefert wird.
Aber jetzt kommt sie über den Mac App Store und so. Wenn, dann startest du wahrscheinlich nur noch den Mac App Store von deinem Stick oder der DVD und...
Nee, aber auch hier so beigelegte CD und so ein Scheiß, ne? Ich mein, das ist ja dann auch noch so eine Mini-CD, die sowieso einfach, wo es einfach mal gar nicht geht, ja? Wovon träumen die, dass die Leute immer noch diese großen PC-Schachteln haben, so mit externem CD-Laufwerk? Oder so mehrere 5,25 Zoll-Slot-Ins?
Hast du nicht dein externes...
Gibt's das überhaupt noch? Wird das überhaupt noch gekauft, diese geschrumpften Mainframes?
Klar. Gamer-PCs. Die Games kommen auch immer noch alle auf.
Die müssen auch jetzt alle leuchten, oder nicht?
Das auch. Obwohl, mit Steam, da muss man ja auch keine optischen Medien mehr einlegen, da kann man ja auch alles runterladen, oder?
Ich guck mich nicht so an zum Thema Spiele und PCs.
Das ist alles online.
Ich spiele nur noch Minecraft und da kommt auch alles von...
Und es kommt alles online? Dann kommt eigentlich die iPad-Version endlich mal. Würde ich mir vielleicht auch mal angucken.
Alles so eine Sache. Und was hast du dir geholt?
Diese 510er mit SATA 3. Aber dann dachte ich mir, Denis hat jetzt hier tausendmal schon vorhin berichtet und wird ja alles super sein, dann komm ich gerade hier noch in den Club und schraub die rein. Dann meinte er, ja, dann musst du hier SMC Reset machen, damit er auf das 6-Gigabit SATA 3 Interface switcht, sonst hast du nur 3. Dann musst du noch hier mit der Library Core Frameworks, mit der Trim Support, ja, ok, also erstmal noch ein bisschen frickeln.
Ja, kannst du aber auch alles lassen.
Nee, also wenn ich mir schon eine SATA 3 SSD kaufe, dann will ich eine SATA 3 haben. 500 MB lesen und 300 MB schreiben.
Meinst du echt, das bringt das Ding?
Bei anderen Tech hier bei den Tests natürlich nicht ganz, aber bei Sequential Read und Sequential Write sind die entweder über OCC oder kurz dahinter. Also die ist auf jeden Fall schon rattenschnell. Bei Random Read und Random Write nicht so ganz, aber das ist im Mittelfeld. Bei anderen Tech, diese Seite, ist ja wirklich goldwertig. Die machen ja sowas wie Deep Preview für Hardware.
Deep Preview?
Nee, nee, dpreview.com, das ist so die Fotonerd-Seite. Da machen sie so Reviews irgendwie 11, 12 Seiten lang und gucken sich und machen Fototests. Und du kannst auf so einer Matrix interaktiv dann das gleiche Motiv mit unterschiedlichen Kameras vergleichen. Und die gehen halt immer so richtig total ab, wenn sie eine Kamera testen. Und das auch, also ich würde mich mal, wenn IMDB, die gibt es ja schon auch sehr lange, die Preview gibt es auch schon echt lange. Würde mich mal glatt interessieren, seit wann es die gibt. Die Seite sieht auch nicht wahnsinnig hübsch aus, aber...
Die steht bestimmt in der englischen Wikipedia.
Also die sind schon...
Habst du da überhaupt schon digitale Fotografie?
Erstmal die Webseite aufmachen und dann das Video.
Also die sind wirklich schon auch sehr lange dabei.
Ich reserviere mir mal rasch zeitmaschinentest.de. Wobei, derjenige, der sie erfindet, kriegt die Domänen trotzdem noch vor mir.
Und dieses anderen Tech, da kann man halt so SSDs sich so irgendwie seitenlange Benchmarks und alles irgendwie durchlesen und sich verwirren lassen.
Das andere Tech wurde 1997 ergründet von einem 15-Jährigen.
Nein, nein, krass.
Ja, gut, dass wir auch schon dabei waren. Jetzt müssen wir uns nicht schämen.
Die Preview und anderen Tech-Featuren wurden jetzt niedergeschrieben für die Show-Notes. Hören Sie zu.
Intel SSD 510.
Der seichte Tastenanschlag von Tim Friedlach.
Bluetooth-Keyboard.
So, haben wir das hier überhaupt schon erwähnt?
Bitcoin ist alles falsch.
Ja, das haben wir schon erwähnt.
Gut, dann nehme ich das mal auf.
Zu Bitcoins haben wir noch zwei Dinge ganz weit unten. Ganz weit unten in den Show-Notes. Das ist das, was ich von was da heran kopiert habe. Kann man ja vielleicht an der Stelle nochmal erwähnen. Zum ersten fand ich heute sehr lustig der Bundesverband der deutschen, wie heißt das, der Digitalwirtschaft. Der Bundesverband Digitale Wirtschaft BVWEV wollte mal ein bisschen bekannt werden und hat darum mal vor Bitcoins gewarnt. Und zwar, dass die alle ganz böse wäre. Und zwar, durch die Nutzung von Bitcoins als Zahlungsmittel wird die notwendige Kontrolle durch den Staat in den Fällen von Steuerhinterziehung oder Geldwäsche unmöglich. Deswegen sind Bitcoins schlichtweg gefährlich und haben das Potenzial, die gesamte Gesellschaft eben durch Steuerhinterziehung, Geldwäsche oder andere illegale Geschäfte nachhaltig zu schaden. Das ist ein offizielles Statement. Kling ich hier gerade irgendwie ein bisschen dumpf? Kann das sein?
Nee?
Und dann kling ich so, dann bin ich das einfach nicht. Und das andere Ding ist, das fand ich ganz, das hab ich heute bei Fefe gelesen. Der hat sich ganz furchtbar darüber aufgeregt. Das war sehr süß. Ich schäm immer voll, wie er so putzig rumhoppelt und auf seinen Stuhl ganz aufgeregt.
Nee, der ist ganz anders dabei.
Meinst du? Meinst du, er ist total entspannt?
Das ist das Phänomen bei Fefe. Also wenn du den nur liest, denkst du dir, was muss das für ein Freak sein? Aber wenn du den echt siehst, dann sitzt er halt so da, so Buddha-mäßig und lacht sich halt auch immer so kaputt. Also der nimmt das schon, glaube ich, eher locker und freut sich so, dass er mal wieder irgendwie Leute trollen kann oder so.
Und zwar, auf jeden Fall hat er so eine italienische bit.it, weiß nicht, wie das ausgesprochen wird, hat so ein JavaScript gebaut, das baust du in die Seite ein und dann generiert jeder, der auf deine Seite kommt, im Hintergrund für dich Bitcoins per JavaScript. Solange du auf der Seite drauf bist. Das heißt, wir könnten das jetzt beim WebEx schon auf der Seite einbinden. Die Leute, die das dann als Podcast auf der Seite hören, die würden dann für uns die ganze Zeit Bitcoins generieren.
Cool, das würde sozusagen besser funktionieren, umso höher die Verweildauer ist.
Genau, also endlich mal...
Aber es bringt halt nichts.
Es bringt quasi gar nichts, weil ich...
Außer Leute zu erneuen und Batteries zu drainen.
Oh mein Gott, also es ist jetzt, die haben hier so, bei mir in Chrome haben die 9000 Hashes pro Sekunde. Das ist im Vergleich dazu, dass das unglaublich langsame Bitcoin-Programm hat irgendwie 700.000 Hashes pro Sekunde und so eine Grafikkarte, ich weiß nicht, was sie schafft, aber...
Mega-Hashes.
Mega-Hashes pro Sekunde. Also es ist nicht mehr als ein Gag, aber ich finde die Idee eigentlich ganz putzig, dass Leute sozusagen, dadurch, dass man könnte theoretisch irgendwann mal ein Prinzip werden, um so Webseiten zu refinanzieren. Und zwar nicht nur nach irgendwie schnellen Klicks, nicht nur auf den schnellen Klick scharf sein, sondern auch so nach Verweildauer. Also gute Inhalte, die man auch lesen möchte, dass man die dann auch, dass man einfach so lange rechnet der Rechner halt für den.
Find ich gar nicht so schlecht.
So, jetzt können wir das Thema Bitcoins aber auch erstmal abschließen, oder? So, worauf haben wir jetzt Lust?
Auf alles außer Tiernahrung.
Soll ich mal hier ein bisschen...
Wir schieben die WWDC noch eine Weile nach hinten. Da sind wir noch überhaupt nicht in Stimmung.
Die Sahnenstücke heben wir uns immer zum Schluss auf. Sonst schalten die doch dann gleich wieder ab. Bleiben Sie dran! Schalten Sie nicht weg. Gleich nach der Kindle-Werbung.
Dann gibt's wirklich WWDC. Auf meinem Blog hab ich darüber geschrieben und hab Böse dafür auf die Fresse gekriegt, wie ich dann so was Negatives über das Kindle... Ich hab so ein Kindle bekommen.
Fangen wir vorne an. Seit wann hast du ein Kindle?
Ich hab seit... Seit wann hab ich ein Kindle? Seit zwei Wochen oder so was. Also ich hab ab 1.8. einen neuen Job. Und dann war dann so die Frage, Max, musst du viel Doku lesen? Willst du dafür ein Kindle haben? Und ich meine, ein technisches Gerät, das sag ich doch nicht. Nein, ich bin auch nicht bekloppt. Und jetzt hab ich hier so ein Kindle. Und ich muss sagen, so... Ich hab so ein bisschen den Artikel oder den Eindruck von diesem ganzen... Gerade Johnny hier bei Spreeblick hat einen extrem positiven Artikel über das Ding geschrieben und ich hab mir dann wirklich sonst was darunter vorgestellt. Und ich muss sagen... Der kostet... also das ist jetzt die WLAN-Version, die kostet 140 Euro.
Also ist nicht...
Ist eigentlich relativ billig.
Was heißt die WLAN-Version? Die hat nur WLAN?
Es gibt eine Version mit nur WLAN und es gibt eine Version mit WLAN und 3G. Wobei 3G ist nicht normales ich schieb meine SIM-Karte rein 3G, sondern da ist halt eine SIM-Karte drinnen. Und die ist fest eingebaut, die funktioniert auch in wohl erstaunlich vielen Ländern. Also machst du dir einfach eigentlich keine Sorgen. Also wenn du bei Amazon irgendein Buch kaufst, dann gehst du auf deren Webseite, kaufst ein Buch und dir ist total egal, in welchem Netz du jetzt gerade eingebucht bist.
Das ist sozusagen mit dem Kaufpreis abgegolten.
Ein bisschen problematisch ist es, wenn du, man kann ja auch per E-Mail Dokumente draufschicken auf das Ding, das ist per WLAN kostenlos, per UMTS Kostezahl. Der kostet 25 Cent, glaube ich, pro Megabyte, wobei auch immer so auch 50 Kilobyte in einer Mail zählen als 25 Cent. Also wenn du da per 3G irgendwie Dokumente hinschickst, dann...
Also du hast schon einen Provider-Vertrag, wo du dann gebildet wirst, oder was?
Nee, das läuft dann über Amazon. Das ist jetzt so meine Vermutung. Also soweit ich weiß, hat man da wirklich nichts zu tun mit irgendeinem Provider. Amazon ist dein ANC-Ansprechpartner. Du kriegst das Ding auch personalisiert, auf dein Account.
Soweit so gut.
Ich finde das Display... Also ich habe ja viel über die unglaubliche Bildschärfung und den Kontrastreichtum von diesem Display gelesen. Und es ist so dieses berühmte... Wenn man es unter prallem Sonnenlicht liest, dann ist es auch... Dann hat man eine extrem gute Bildqualität. Also man kann das unter hellem Licht extrem gut lesen, da wo das normale Display total versagt, da kommt das erst zur vollen Stärke. So bei jetzt so Zimmerlicht wie hier, ist es eher so ein dunkleres, graueres Umweltpapiergrau. So der Hintergrund. Und das schwarz ist so ein Anthracit-Ton. Und von Bildschärfe konnte ich jetzt auch nicht so wahnsinnig viel feststellen, weil ich finde das Bild, also das hat eine Auflösung von 800 x 600 Pixeln. Das ist okay, das ist nichts Schlimmes. Aber es ist jetzt nicht so, dass man, oh Gott, oh Gott, das ist ja das Schärfste, was ich jemals gesehen habe, sondern man sieht also gerade bei Schrift, so beim kleinen O zum Beispiel sieht man doch sehr deutlich, dass da Anti-Aliasing dran ist und so.
Ja, ist halt wie ein schlecht gedrucktes Buch, ne?
Ist wie ein schlecht gedrucktes Buch, genau. Und was ich halt echt, das User-Interface finde ich sehr, sehr gewöhnungsbedürftig. Also ich habe so jeden, der man es in die Hand gedrückt hat, jeder toucht erstmal auf dem Display rum. Du warst halt zuerst, der es nicht gemacht hat.
Doch, ich hab's auch gemacht.
Das ist wirklich krass. Du drückst das irgendwie immer in deine Hand. Die Leute wissen, dass es keinen toucht kann, aber sie drücken trotzdem auf dem Display rum. Und es ist halt, also du bedienst das da unten im Wesentlichen über dieses kleine Steuerkreuz. Und das finde ich total füsselig. Und irgendwie...
Das hat ja nicht mal Syntax-Highlighting.
Ja, das ist also so die ganze Formatierung, das ist sowieso mein Spaß für sie nicht. Man hat nur zwei Schriften zur Auswahl. Das muss man also drehen, muss man über das Menü. Da ist eine Taste, da ist die... Guck mal, diese runde Taste da. Die Tasten sind alle absolut gleich. Hier unten diese Taste, da drüber kann man dann einstellen, welche Schrift man haben will und in welcher Richtung man das Display gedreht haben will. Ja, so in etwa war auch mein Gefühl so.
Ich will so nicht Bücher lesen.
Und ich finde diese Tasten an der Seite, diese Weiterblättern und Vorwärtsblättern-Tasten, ich weiß nicht, wie das euch gibt, ich hab da auch... Ich komm da nicht gut ran. Ich halte das so in die Hand und das ist, mein Daumen liegt 5 Millimeter neben dieser Weiterblättern-Taste. Und das ist nicht so, dass ich nicht bereit wäre, meinen Daumen ein bisschen weiter zum Rand zu verschieben, aber dann kann ich das dann auch nicht so gut machen.
Zu viel für die Menschen, zumal es dazu auch noch so ein pfiffiges Täschchen gibt mit Lämpchen, was den Nachteil der Mann... Gib mir das Teil auch mal, ich hab's nicht so richtig.
Ich find die auch zu klein. Ich weiß nicht, ich hätt's ja gerne so vom Format ein bisschen größer tatsächlich.
Das ist eigentlich auch das, was mich so ein bisschen... Ich mein, das ist halt... Eigentlich hat das Ding Taschenbuchformat, nur dass eben 50% der Fläche draufgehen für eine Tastatur. Also ich mein, wenn das Ding nichts anderes wäre als das. Das Problem ist, dass sie halt keinen Touch haben.
Genau.
Und wer war das hier? Der neue Nuke, glaub ich, von Barnes & Noble. Der hat jetzt, glaub ich, als erster E-Ink mit Touch. Schätz mal, das wird dann aber mit Kindle auch bald einzuhalten. Also das könnte dann das Problem lösen und wenn sie sich dann halt auch zu einer On-Screen-Tastatur durchregen, was ja eigentlich naheliegt, dann würden sie eben hier auch diese Fläche komplett nutzen. Und ich denke, dann ist das dann auch schon wieder ein bisschen was anderes. Trotzdem, um so ein Programmierbücher, du hast ja hier auch gerade eins auf, und das irgendwie zu lesen...
Das bricht schon ziemlich um.
Da ist eigentlich so unter A5, finde ich. Da ist das iPad ein gewisser... Also das ist gerade so die Grenze, würde ich sagen, das iPad. Also kleiner als das iPad.
Also so wie ein O'Reilly-Buch.
Aber das iPad hat wiederum nicht genug Pixel.
Was ich... Naja, das hat ja weniger Pixel als ein iPad. Das ist halt ja 800 x 600.
Ja, aber das liest sich besser als der Text auf dem iPad.
Find ich... Find ich tatsächlich nicht.
Also so ein LCD-Screen, das hat schon deutlich mehr Schärfe.
Pinster?
Ja, finde ich.
Ja, also beim iPad sieht man halt auch so die Pixel...
Da ist der Kontrast einfach viel besser. Und der Kontrast ist halt bei dem... Also bei Text, bei Anti-Aliasten-Text ist er wirklich schlechter, deutlich. Also das Ding mit der Sonne, das stimmt einfach.
Das Ding mit der Sonne stimmt.
Das iPad draußen in der Sonne, das kannst du vergessen.
Ja, für mich ist halt die Frage, wie oft sitze ich tatsächlich draußen in der Sonne und will irgendwas lesen und wie oft liege ich abends im Bett und will irgendwas lesen. Letzterer Fall kommt wesentlich häufiger vor und dann möchte ich nicht extra eine Lampe anmachen.
Ja, das ist auch ein absolut gültiger Punkt. Wobei ich wiederum im Bett ist mir das iPad zu groß. Dann nehme ich das iPhone, ja klar. Ich kann hier auf der Seite liegen und dann noch dieses Schweinein.
Ich hab das, ich leg das so auf die Seite.
Das geht eigentlich super. Ich liege mich auf die Seite, mach diesen Ständer, dass das so hochkant ist. Ich hab doch hier dieses Smart-Cover und dann stelle ich das so hin. Hochkant im Smart-Cover.
Achso, du hast ja ein iPad 2.
Ich mach das Bild auf die Seite, sodass ich so schön mit dem Kopf auf dem Kissen liegen kann, mich einfach auf die Seite lege. Dann kann ich auch die Hände runternehmen und brauche nicht die ganze Zeit das zu halten, sondern es steht so einfach auf dem Bett und ich kann gut lesen und ich kann im Zweifelsfall auch mal ein Filmchen gucken oder sowas. Und wenn ich weiterblättern will, dann muss ich kurz aufs Display ditchen. Aber das geht echt entspannt.
Gut, da macht das Smart-Cover Sinn.
Da macht das total Sinn. Und das geht halt mit dem Kindle nicht. Das musst du halt die ganze Zeit in der Hand halten.
Andererseits ist das Ding aber auch so scheiß-leicht. Wir haben jetzt auch genug Fläche zum drauffassen und unbeabsichtigt Tasten drücken.
Furchtbar.
Es gibt sogar eine Zym-Taste.
Ja, es gibt Tasten für... Vor allen Dingen, was ich auch... Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das jemand ernsthaft wirklich getestet hat. Weil dieses Steuerkreuz, das ist... Also das hat so einen Cursor-Block. Und diese Richtungstasten sind extrem schmal. Und mir ist es schon sehr häufig passiert, dass ich beim Runterdrücken noch auf die Back-Taste gerutscht bin. Und wenn man auf die Back-Taste rutscht, dann ist man irgendwo, wo man vorher nicht war. Und weil das immer noch ein bisschen verzögert ist, weil dieses Display nicht sofort reagiert, sondern es immer noch so eine gewisse Bewegung noch hat, ist man jedes Mal total verwirrt, wo man jetzt eigentlich gelandet ist. Also es ist so dieses E-Ink mag ja alles ganz toll sein, aber sorry, der Stein der Weisen ist das noch nicht.
Gut, die Geschmäcker sind verschieden, sag ich mal.
Und was leider... Ja, jetzt sind es Leute, die sagen, sie kriegen nach einer Weile beim iPad Kopfschmerzen. Bei mir ist es wirklich genau umgekehrt. Ich hab's probiert, auf dem Ding was zu lesen und ich kann mit Hintergrundbeleuchtung auf einem iPad-Display, kann ich stundenlang ohne Probleme lesen. Dagegen bei dem Ding beim Kindle, wenn es zu dunkel wird im Raum oder irgendwie sowas, klar, soll ich Licht anmachen, aber passiert mir nun mal, dass ich dann lese und es wird dunkel und ich krieg das nicht mit und ich vergesse es und dann krieg ich es erst daran, dass ich Kopfschmerzen habe. Das passiert mir nicht beim iPad.
Ich sag mal, your mileage may vary. Ich bin da immer noch nicht so ganz, ich meine diese jüngsten Erfolgsmeldungen von Amazon mit ihrem Kindle und dass sie ja jetzt mehr E-Books verkaufen als Books.
Genau, zuerst waren es mehr Bücher, dann mehr Taschenbücher und jetzt mehr Bücher.
Genau, wobei sie sich immer noch nicht zu irgendwelchen Zahlen äußern. Also ich glaube, es gibt immer noch keine einzige offizielle Meldung, wie viele Kindles es denn nun wirklich gibt.
Wie viele Kindles?
Ja, wie viele sie wirklich verkauft haben. Diese Zahl ist meiner Kenntnis nach bislang nicht genannt worden. Das heißt immer nur genug und viele und passt schon. Und mehr als das und so. Und ist jetzt das erfolgreichste Produkt und da kann man sich mal irgendwas draus zusammenlesen. Aber das hat auch so eine riesige Spannbreite, dass eben das auch nicht fassbar ist. Ich kann jetzt auch abends einschlafen, ohne diese Zahl zu wissen, aber ich wüsste es ganz gern mal, um mal das wirklich zu bewerten. Und das auch wirklich mal in Relation stellen zu können. Man, das ist ganz offensichtlich ein ganz anderes Produkt als dieses iPad.
Nochmal zweieinhalb Sätze vielleicht. Der Akku, ich hab den noch nie geladen. Und der war, als ich ihn bekommen habe, war er halb voll. Und jetzt ist er so auf ein Drittel runter.
Nach was?
Na vielleicht ein Viertel.
Wie viel im Zeitraum?
Na nach zwei Wochen nicht intensiver Nutzung, gelegentlicher Nutzung.
Das ist schon cool.
Also dieses Wasser bewerben, dass der so bei normaler Benutzung einen Monat durchhält, glaube ich sofort. Und dann braucht er allerdings ewig zum Laden. Die Verpackung war cool. Die Verpackung ist echt geil von dem Ding, weil die ist so total auf Versandhandel ausgerichtet. Das ist keine Verpackung, die dafür da ist, im Geschäft rumzuliegen, weil das ist halt... Du kriegst deine Transportbox, deine so von UPS reingereicht. Und dann hast du unten so eine Lasche dran, die machst du auf, und dann hast du sofort das Gerät an der Hand. Und das ist dann so alles Öko und alles Umweltpapier und sowas. Das ist echt schick gemacht. Nicht so schick, finde ich irgendwie.
Aber ohne Magic.
Ohne Magic. Ich hab ja diesen Artikel genannt, das Unmagische.
Kann man vielleicht bei der Bestellung noch mit Magic anklicken können? So wie Geschenkpapier und so, dass man sich auch noch etwas Magic beilegen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man das mit dem Geschenkpapier verpacken kann.
Ja, du kannst immer sagen, es ist ein Geschenk. Das geht bei Amazon, glaube ich, generell. Also ich weiß nicht, ob es beim Kindle vielleicht ausgerechnet nicht geht, aber...
Keine Ahnung, weil du hast keine... Also wenn du so ein iPad bekommst, dann hast du diese Apple-Transfort-Verpackung, dann ist da in der Verpackung noch mal die eigentliche Verpackung drinne. Das ist bei dem Ding halt nicht so. Sondern du kriegst einfach keine Box dazu. Es ist eine extrem kleine Kiste. Und die ratscht unten auf, die kriegst du auch nie wieder zu, wenn die einmal auf ist. Also die ist dann halt mit so einem, wie so diese neuen Pizzaschachteln, so ein Tratsch. Und dann ist die offen. Und dann hast du das Ding und kannst es direkt einschalten und laden kannst du auch erst mal, brauchst du nicht, weil...
Ist schon geladen.
Naja, ist halb voll, so der Akku. Und das reicht erst mal für zwei Wochen.
Tim wird müde, weil wir nicht so über Mac-Produkte reden.
Ja, jetzt noch ganz kurz.
Ich bin müde, weil ich viel zu wenig geschlafen habe und früh aufgestanden bin und heute schon viel Action gehabt hab. Aber nee, ich find das jetzt... Ich wär mich ja gar nicht gegen das Thema.
Es ist sehr spannend. Nein.
Ich halt ihn auch fest.
Ich denk einfach nur so ein bisschen darüber nach.
Gleich können wir über Nokia reden, Tim.
Was der Trend sein könnte. Ich will mich mit diesen ganzen Content-Meldungen jetzt auch von Apple beschäftige ich mich auch nicht so innig. Ich hab da allerdings auch so Sachen mit E-Ink und Bildschirmen kombinieren. Ich hab so den Eindruck, dass Apple mit dem iPad und mit den LCDs den Trend. Ich meine, ich wäre überrascht, wenn Apple nicht über die technologische zu erwartende Entwicklung von LCDs für die nächsten drei Jahre ziemlich klar Bescheid weiß. Die setzen nicht auf irgendeine Technik, von der sie nicht, zumindest für die nächsten zwei, drei Jahre, ziemlich genau wissen, wohin die Reise geht. In dem möglichen Rahmen, in dem man sich sicher sein kann bei diesen Dingen. Also, was weiß ich, wenn sie zu dem Zeitpunkt, als sie auf Intel gewechselt sind, dann wussten sie nicht nur, dass es jetzt den Core 2 Duo gibt und haben dann Hello gerufen, als dann auch die E-Serie kam, sondern die haben sich wahrscheinlich schön in Handschrift vom Chef auf Büttenpapier das mal aufschreiben lassen, wie denn so die Roadmap ist für die nächsten paar Jahre und was da sozusagen zu holen ist. Und so muss es auch hier laufen. Und ich frag mich halt, wohin das so hinläuft mit den Möglichkeiten Touch E-Ink, Touch LCD, Kontrast etc. Gibt ja auch schon wieder so ein, ich will nicht so sehr in dieser Gerüchteküche rumstromen, aber es ist natürlich schon so, dass das iPad darunter leidet, dass der Bildschirm nicht gut genug ist und zwar nicht gut genug im Sinne von Sonne. Also Sonneneinstrahlung, generell eben Helligkeit damit verbunden, weil bei LCD musst du ja immer gegen die Sonne anstrahlen quasi. Das hat sich ja viel verbessert. Dann eben auch so eine etwaige E-Ink-Fähigkeit. Da gab es halt mal dieses Patent mit irgendwie hat beides und so, dass du noch so E-Ink über dem LCD drüber hast und so. Keine Ahnung, ob das überhaupt realistisch ist. Neulich dann dieses Gerücht mit LCD, so mit depolarisierenden Filtern, sodass du auch mit einer Sonnenbrille den Bildschirm wieder lesen kannst, was derzeit aufgrund der Art und Weise, wie LCD abstrahlt, wohl sehr schwierig ist.
Auch so ein Punkt.
Draußen sein, Sonnenbrille tragen, das ist Kalifornien, Mann.
Aber wie viel Prozent der Leute haben eine polarisierte Sonnenbrille?
Wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, ist das einfach ein generelles Problem aller Sonnenbrillen, die UV-Schutz haben. Weil, so wie der UV-Schutz funktioniert, wirkt er dem LCD entgegen. Aber ich hab tatsächlich selber noch nicht mit einer Sonnenbrille getestet. Worauf wollte ich jetzt eigentlich hinaus? Ich denke, dass die Leute immer noch ein größeres Interesse haben an einem Universalgerät als an einem Spezialgerät. Allerdings, damals war es so, dass es preislich sich im selben Segment abgespielt hat. 400, 500 Dollar, bzw. das iPad gab es, als wir das so diskutiert haben, noch gar nicht in der Form. Aber wenn man eine signifikante Menge Geld ausgibt, so wie für ein iPhone und so, dann sinkt natürlich der Wunsch danach noch für eine einzige Anwendung noch ein anderes Gerät in einer ähnlichen Preisklasse zu haben. Dadurch, dass es Amazon gelungen ist, dieses Teil auf 100 und paar zerquetschte runterzudrücken, gegebenenfalls sogar mit dem Potential, in so einem magischen 99-Dollar-Range zu landen, was man durchaus vorstellen kann. Deswegen hat das Ding seine Konkurrenzfähigkeit behalten. Und offensichtlich ist Buchlesen dann doch ausreichend interessant für viele Leute, sich sowas zu kaufen. Da ich nicht so ein intensiver Buchleser bin, war mir das immer sehr schwer, das einzuschätzen. Trotzdem denke ich, dass das iPad in the long run einfach viel erfolgreicher sein wird, auch wenn man es nicht direkt miteinander vergleichen kann.
Was mir aufgefallen ist, von der Auswahl her, ist das iPad erstaunlicherweise ein wesentlich besseres Buchlesegerät als das Kindle. Hier kannst du wirklich nur das Amazon-Zeug drauflesen. Wohingegen für das iPad gibt es im Zweifelsfall alles. Wo es wirklich anfängt lächerlich zu werden, ist bei Zeitungen und sowas. Ich hab mir hierfür mal die Zeit gekauft, für das Kindle und den Kindle. Das sieht aus wie Homepage 1997. Das ist wirklich was, das will man nicht. Such das mal kurz raus. Das hat keine Bilder. Das hat als Präsentation, mal sehen, wo ist er? Das ist eine Liste mit, hier nochmal für euch, links steht das Ressort und rechts sind alle Artikel, die dazu stehen. Und das war's. Dann kann man die einzelnen Artikel auswählen und da sind keine Bilder, keine Anreistexte, das ist gar nichts. Wenn ich mir so angucke, was auf dem iPad so, da ist lange nicht der Stein der Weisen gefunden, aber was da an Lesemöglichkeiten möglich ist und das mit dieser Zeitvergleiche, das sieht mir doch schon ein bisschen sehr nach 1990.
Ja, weil ich finde, an der Stelle ist das auch, glaube ich, was anderes. Also da kann man das wahrscheinlich auch gar nicht so miteinander vergleichen. Warum nicht? Das, was du mir da gezeigt hast, das sieht für mich so wirklich wie das aus, was ich als Inhaltsverzeichnis auch in einer gedruckten Zeitung umzeitbar finde.
Das ist nicht sehr viel anders.
Nee, bei einer Zeitung hast du so ein riesen Format und hast Bilder drin und da hast du große Überschriften.
Naja, klar, ich mein, dass so ein Kind nicht den A0-Papier ist, ist ja wohl jedem klar. Ja, aber es ist halt mit dem A0-elektronisches Device, werden wir auch nie haben.
Mit dem iPad probieren sie es halt so in die Richtung zu kommen, indem sie so ein bisschen rumscrollen machen. Bilder kannst du auf jeden Fall vernünftig und so dieses ganze Zeug. Also das Nachrichteninhalte wird man auf dem iPad und kann man hundertmal besser lesen als auf dem Kindle.
Also ich hätte gerne eigentlich nur einen größeren Kindle mit ohne Tasten und reduziert nur aufs schöne typografisch und ästhetische Buchlesen reduzierte Gerät, wo ich meine ganzen PDFs und egal was ich da so habe, raufschmeiße und schön lesen kann. Aber das alles gibt es in so diesen E-Book-Rädern für mich nicht und allerdings auch nicht im iPad momentan, vor allen Dingen wegen der Auflösung. Aber zum anderen strengt es mich halt auch ein bisschen an, so dieses beleuchtete Display des Abends zu lesen. Also irgendwie mit so digital Buchlesen bin ich bisher nicht so glücklich.
Abends musst du eh beleuchten.
Jaja, aber dann habe ich lieber so eine Raumbeleuchtung tatsächlich als so... Naja, aber wir können ja vielleicht mal von unserem großen Themenblumenstrauß mal so langsam in den nächsten Kanal schwenken.
Ich hole mir so lange noch mal was Martiges. Ich hole mir so lange noch mal eine Mate. Möchten wir noch jemanden was?
Du kannst schon mal frisch nachladen. Hier ist bestimmt bald alle und so, wie ich hier angemeldet bin.
Du hast noch jemand von den Hörern?
Ich kann jetzt auf jeden Fall berichten, während wir hier so schön über Kindle und so, während da so referiert wurde, habe ich jetzt hier dieses MacBook Pro installiert, habe den SMC Reset hervorgerufen, der jetzt dann im System Profiler dafür sorgt, dass da steht, dass der Nekro...
Was ist denn SMC in dem zu sagen mal?
Na, das ist der, was früher N oder V-Ram oder P-Ram Reset war.
Also das Memory der Platte sozusagen, das Flash-Ram der Platte oder was?
Oder ja, Parameter-Ram halt, was auch immer. Naja, auf jeden Fall steht nämlich, wenn nur die SSD einbaust, steht halt, ja ja, es alle SATA 3, 6 Gigabit, aber der Negotiated SATA Speed ist halt nur 3 Gigabit und dann meinte Denis halt vorhin, ich muss mal diesen SMC Reset machen und schwuppdiwupp war es jetzt auch Negotiated auf 6 Gigabit. Und dann hat ja Denis gemeint, damit ich Trim Support hab, muss ich jetzt hier diesen Trim Enabler anmachen und früher musste man das von Hand kopieren, musste man sich so eine gepatchte Score Framework in die Library kopieren und wenn es nicht geklappt hat, wird zurückkopiert und jetzt gibt es so ein Tool, wo man einfach auf Patch klickt, gibt es bei Make Update Trim Enabler und dann hat man auch bei Third Party SSDs Trim an.
Und das funktioniert doch vernünftig?
SMC also System Management Controller.
Das ist das, wo dann irgendwie plötzlich auch der Bildschirmhintergrund resettet wird oder irgendwie so eine ganz komische Einstellung von Mac OS, wo man dachte, dass das auch in irgendwelchen Präferenzen liegt.
Aber gemeint ist der System Management Controller vom Mac?
Und danach ist er negativ. Genau, nicht auf der Platte.
Das mit dem Bildschirmhintergrund, das klingt insofern logisch, weil mir ist aufgefallen, dass wenn man externen Bildschirm anschließt, dann kriegt man immer einen Default Bildschirm. Also man kann für jeden Bildschirm, den man besitzt, ein anderes Hintergrundbild auswählen.
Festplatte, SMC, Hintergrundbildschirm...
Weil ich gerade meinte, dass beim SMC Reset vergisst der Mac OS ein paar Einstellungen, wo man dachte, dass sie in irgendwelchen Preferences-Files liegen müssten.
Ach so, und die aber tatsächlich in dem...
Bildschirmhintergrund oder irgend sowas, oder Bildschirmschoner war es. Bildschirmschoner? Eine von diesen, so ein...
Textauswahl-Farbe vielleicht?
Irgend so ein komisches...
Die Textauswahl-Farbe, mal früher stand die mal im P-Ram drinnen, vor ganz, ganz langen Zeiten, so zu System 7-Zeiten.
Da hat man die Information, von wo er bootet.
Naja, anyway, auf jeden Fall ist jetzt hier, hab ich hier einen neuen MacBook Pro, hab ich SSD, hab ich 6 Gigabit und hab ich Trim an.
Und jetzt fährst du hoch, fährst du runter, fährst du hoch, fährst du runter.
So, fahr ich runter, dauert, schnack, schnack, schnack, Sekunde nur.
Sonst sich hier nicht mal schlafen zu legen, das Ding. Was, ernsthaft? Zeig mal, zeig mal, wie schnell das hofft.
Na, Coil, jetzt machen wir das mal.
Zeig hier.
Alles aus, ok.
Und 3, 2, 1, Lift off.
Hoffentlich stoppt auch jemand.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 8.
Also so ein Chromebook wär jetzt schon da. Boah, jetzt kommt erst der Kugelspar.
16, 17, 18, 19. Naja, gut, die ersten 6 Sekunden gehen da vielleicht nochmal runter, aber so geht's schneller.
Na komm, das mit dem Finder, das war schon...
Das EFI dauert tatsächlich auch sehr lange. Also beim PC ist zum Beispiel das BIOS, dauert auch gefühlte 20 Sekunden, bis er durchgerührt ist. Und dann, wenn du sowas wie Ubuntu oder Windows startest.
Damit können wir beim Wetten das auftreten.
Ein Prittlauf macht jedes BIOS-Geräusch nach.
Ich meine, früher hätte ich dir sagen können, was ein Computer tut, indem ich einfach 60 Sekunden lang seiner Festplatte zugehört habe. Mit dem SSD ist der Sport auch vorbei.
Dieses übliche Ohr auflegen.
Und die Leute, die immer so keinen Einblick haben und gar nicht wissen, wie einfach das eigentlich ist, die schauen dann immer so verstört an.
So, oh mein Computer, guck mal!
Ja, so, sei erstmal ganz leise. Ohr auf die Platte.
Beim Rammeraustauschen finde ich diesen Voodoo-Zauber immer ganz hübsch, dass man so erstmal immer Metall anfassen, dann da anfassen. Da glauben auch immer alle, man wäre irre.
Eigentlich sollte man auch so ein paar Antistatik-Armbänder auch, ne? Eigentlich müsste man sowas gleich ankommen.
Ja, oder vielleicht einfach noch ein paar Teelichter anzünden und so an den vier Ecken des Raumes verteilen und dann so bitte nicht bewegen jetzt.
Das mach ich Montag zur Keynote.
Kurz die Augen schließen.
Ich glaube, ich mach mal Pylvolt an.
Unser Intro hatte schon recht hier. SSD wird das Dauerthema.
Ja, aber wirklich, das zieht sich jetzt durch Mobile Max schon seit...
Womit wollen wir weitermachen?
Da hatte übrigens Hans einen schönen Tweet noch so abschließend. Ich suche den raus, oder kann ich ihn frei zitieren? Er meinte irgendwie, dass nur Leute einem von SSDs abraten, die selber keine haben.
Das hab ich auch gelesen, das war aber besser formuliert.
Das war halt auch so Wahrheit in 140 Zeichen. Diese Admins bei dem neuen Arbeitgeber, die haben scheinbar selber keine SSDs, auch in dem Fall. Das kann man niemand anderen mehr anbieten.
The only people who tell you not to buy an SSD are the people who don't have one.
Das ist übrigens auch genauso mit dem Mac.
Es gibt auch schon welche, die mal einen Linux installiert haben.
Ich kenne jetzt niemanden, der sich mal einen Mac gekauft hat, der irgendwann angefangen hätte, einem was anderes zu empfehlen. Das ist irgendwie eine Einbahnstraße.
Das Thema hatten wir jetzt auch schon zu Genüge.
Aber ich bin ja naiv.
Willst du hier mal ein bisschen über Nokia reden?
Du hast das eingetragen.
Ich hab das eingetragen.
Ich will ein Mac-Thema.
Mach mal danach, mach mal schön wie wir die C raten.
Ich hab ja das Gefühl, ich hab zu Nokia schon alles gesagt. Ich meine, jetzt passiert halt einfach nur noch das, was...
Ja, was er angekündigt hat, das ist schon wichtig.
Schon im Intro. Ja, okay, gut, jetzt haben sie halt Umsatzwarnung, Pipapo. Ich denke, das wird jetzt einfach noch, das geht jetzt noch ein Jahr so weiter. Und dann haben alle noch mal so ein bisschen Hoffnung nächstes Jahr. Das ist ja vielleicht dann, wenn Windows doch noch mal irgendwas werden könnte. Und dann wird der Spaß dann auch vorbei sein. Und wenn Microsoft cool ist, aber die sind ja nicht cool, bleiben wir noch mal kurz bei dem Thema. Das ist auch wirklich so geil, ja? Jetzt hat sich Microsoft...
Jetzt sitzt du wirklich am Ende. Jetzt hat Tim keinen Bock mehr über Nokia herzuziehen.
Nee, aber ich meine, da gab es auch ein paar schöne Blogposts, die zu dem Thema Warum bitte hat Microsoft Skype gekauft? Wir haben das ja auch schon ein bisschen durchgekaut. Dann habe ich auch schon mehrfach meinen Kopf auf die Tischplatte gehauen. Als das überhaupt anfing mit diesen ganzen Nokia-Meldungen und Microsoft, ihr erinnert euch vielleicht, war ja gleich so meine Vermutung, dass es ja auch auf so ein Buyout hinauslaufen könnte. Wahrscheinlich wäre das immer noch das Glückste, was wir machen könnten. Stattdessen kaufen sie sich für 8,5 Milliarden US-Dollar. Das muss man sich mal auf der Zunge zeigen lassen. 8,5 Milliarden US-Dollar. Wobei ein Großteil davon Schulden sind von Skype. Sie kaufen sich Schulden von so einem Fail-Business-Modell. Wie twittete vorhin einer bei Mobamex, dass die ganzen... Das suche ich mal kurz raus. Das war eigentlich sehr schön. Warte mal, da ist so viel anderes drin. Dass die ganzen anderen Marktteilnehmer würden ja wohl mal...
Ah ja, genau, hier.
Gleich haben wir es.
Das bezog sich glaube ich auf was anderes.
Wir kommen heute hier nicht in den richtigen Fanboy-Schwung.
Ja, ich meine, wieso gibt es hier dieses Padphone-Announcement von Asus? Das sind doch alles Schwachmaten. Hat denn überhaupt noch irgendeiner in dieser IT die Bereitschaft, mal was zu leisten? Stattdessen kommen sie alle nur noch mit Schwachsinnsprodukten.
Hast du das Ding hier gesehen?
Schwachsinnquatsch und keiner versteht mehr überhaupt irgendwas von Computern.
Also das von Habt-Hesa doch ganz nett, oder nicht?
Ja gut, das haben wir ja nun schon lange diskutiert, dass sie ja da eine Chance haben, nur dass eben die HP-Unternehmenskultur zumindest bisher nicht unbedingt jetzt einen Track-Rekord damit hat, dass sie da auch erfolgreich sein werden.
Naja, bis zu einem gewissen Zeitpunkt hat Apple jetzt auch keinen sonderlich großen Track-Rekord damit, irgendwo mit erfolgreich zu werden, bis Steve kam.
Also Unternehmen können sich ja eventuell ändern.
Wie?
Naja, Apple war, als sie Next aufgekauft haben, ging's Apple jetzt auch nicht gerade blendend.
76, das sind jetzt 35 Jahre.
So, und die letzten zehn Jahre waren gut.
Die letzten zehn Jahre waren gut, ja.
Die ersten zehn Jahre waren auch sehr gut.
Ich würde sogar sagen, die ersten 15 Jahre waren okay.
Na, die Ende der 80er-Jahre ging's gar nicht.
Der Apple III war so ein totaler Fehl.
Das war der erste.
Die Lisa, die massenhaft auf irgendwelchen, wie heißt das, Müllverbrennungsunterflügt worden ist.
Na gut, das Ding war noch ein Jahr durch.
Die war durch und der Mac so richtig, also so richtig ein Erfolgsschlager war er auch nicht. Ist ein geiles Gerät, klar, aber wirklich blendend verkauft hat er sich auch nicht. Also klar, cooler Laden, aber jetzt...
Ich kann die Axt wieder weglegen.
Also gut verkauft, ich weiß nicht ganz genau, also Apple hatte damals, so Ende der 80er Jahre, Marktanteile, an die sie jetzt erst langsam wieder rankommen. Also das ist schon so ein Zerrbild. Natürlich wurden damals ganz andere Stückzahlen verkauft, wurden allerdings auch ganz andere Preise genommen. Wir reden hier von Computern, die so im 5-stelligen Bereich gekostet haben, als sie auf den Markt kamen. Und Apples Marktanteile waren in den 80er Jahren gut. Da hatten die noch richtig was zu melden. Und es waren die 90er, die die Katastrophe waren. Weil sie Anfang der 90er Jahre vollständig die Kontrolle über ihren Laden verloren haben, weil sie ihren Gründer rausgeschmissen haben und weil dann einfach Marketing-Hines freigedreht haben. Und der Meinung ist, man müsste jetzt einfach nur denselben Shit und langweilige Boxen bauen und dann haben sie irgendwie ihre Software-Development-Geschichte nicht mehr auf die Reihe bekommen und auch ihr Product-Development war einfach kacke. Und sogar noch in der Phase ist Apple ja noch halbwegs was Wegweisendes gelungen. Was zwar dann jetzt nicht ein Markterfolg war, aber wo ich jetzt nicht sagen würde, das war jetzt vom Produkt her vollkommen scheiße. Sowas wie der Newton zum Beispiel. War an sich, also war nicht richtig positioniert und software-mäßig und Migration und Syncing und so weiter alles noch nicht verstanden gewesen. Aber trotzdem, mit dem iPad reden wir jetzt im Prinzip über die, wie der Newton hätte schon immer sein sollen. Und gut, das kann man jetzt so oder so interpretieren, aber ich finde ja so die pauschale Aussage, dass bei Apple ja immer alles scheiße gewesen wäre und erst jetzt, seit ein paar Jahren ist es gut, finde ich jetzt auch so ein bisschen gewagt, sagen wir es mal so. Aber die anderen enttäuschen mich jetzt, weil eigentlich keiner irgendeine nennenswerte Innovation auf den Tisch liegt. Das ist das, was mich stört. Also ich fände das ja mal gut, wenn Microsoft mal irgendwann mal was Tolles rausbringen würde. Gut, klar, okay, jetzt Kinect. Wow, super, haben sie eingekauft.
Meinetwegen, ja.
Aber wir reden jetzt hier über so ein Device. Von einem Device. Und da ist jetzt, das hat enorme Auswirkungen auf so Teilmärkte, auf den Spielebereich auf jeden Fall, aber natürlich auch so auf den Robotikmarkt. Das ist ein super Ding. Aber insgesamt ist da einfach keine Musik. Da gibt es nichts, wo man sagt, wow, geile Strategie.
Mach mal dieses Dell-Ding auf. Dell-Ding? Oder ist der Link jetzt weg?
Nein, nein, hier ist er.
Das Dell XPS.
Allein dieser Name, wie kann man seine Produkte noch so nennen? Die ganze Zeit bringen wir auch diese Festplatte. X, D, Y, Strich, 57, 43, Strich, Beta, 3, RC, 5, 9, 27, B, Strich, 6.
Mach mal auf, hier Großschau. So, jetzt machen wir die Galerie auf.
X, P, Z, 15, Z. Das können sich die Leute bestimmt merken. Ich würde sagen, die 15-jährigen sind schon unter dem... Ach, das ist dieser MacBook-Klon.
Das sieht aus wie ein chinesischer billiger MacBook-Klon. Das ist echt so sagenhaft.
Das ist das Ding, was FIFA hat?
Nee, das ist jetzt ein total neues Ding.
Das ist auch so ein MacBook-Klon, so ein PC, der aussieht wie ein MacBook.
Und die haben hier in den Fotos das Dell-Ding und das MacBook aufeinander gelegt.
Beim Power-Adapter ist kein ähnlicherer Stecker eingefallen.
Vor allen Dingen finde ich hier auch so geil. Offensichtlich haben sie keinen Unibody drauf gehabt. Da vorne, guck mal, die LEDs bei der Akku-Anzeige sind wirklich auch an der gleichen Stelle. Die haben das irgendwann aus China gegeben und haben gesagt, wir möchten genau das. Und dann haben sie gesagt, genau das können wir nicht. Na gut, so gut wie es geht, ran.
Sieht scheiße aus.
Und sieht total scheiße aus. Und ist in der Presseerklärung drin. Steht ja auch drin. Die hat dann auch noch eine schöne Runde gemacht, dass dieses Ding, hier dieses Dell XPS 15Z, falls ihr euch hier zum Beispiel unseren Amazon-Link kaufen wollt, seien das...
Darauf soll ich liegen?
Seien das dünnste 15 Zoll Notebook der Welt. Das dünnste? Das dünnste. Und dann steht unterm Sternchen, mit dünnstes 15 Zoll Notebook der Welt, meinen wir, wir hatten in unserem Testlabor zum Vermessen ein Gerät von Asus, eins von HP, eins von... Wir hatten kein Gerät von Apple da. Und hier M-Gadget oder Gizmodo hat danach gemessen, das MacBook 15 Zoll ist tatsächlich dünner. Also sie schreiben...
Aber sie hatten halt gerade keinen Star.
Sie hatten gerade keinen Star, sonst hätten sie es natürlich gern... Sie haben in ihre Presseerklärung geschrieben, mit welchem Gerät sie es nicht verglichen haben, weil es dünner gewesen wäre, weil es dann nicht mehr hinten in den Schirm sein könnte, dass es das dünnste wäre.
Aber hast du auch diesen Artikel gelesen, wo irgendwie noch mal darüber referiert wurde, dass sich als Apple das iPad rausgebracht hat, alle darüber aufgeregt haben, dass es Pat heißt, weil das irgendwie so was wie Damenbinde oder so in Amerika oder so heißt und dann irgendwie alle voll die Witze gemacht haben und da er noch Slate liegt so als der Name auserquoten wurde von Herrn Bollmer und jetzt alle Produkte Pat heißen bis hin zum legendären Patphone. Also man muss ja jetzt schon sagen legendär eigentlich.
Das war geil, oder?
Das war so das Patphone.
Habt ihr diese Präsentation gesehen?
Ist das ernst, dass sie da so ein Handy in so ein Tablett reingesteckt haben?
Ja.
Du kaufst so eins und kriegst zwei?
Buy one, get one free?
Oder ist das so optional?
Ich hab keine Ahnung. Ich vermute mal, weil ja das teuerste an so einem Tablett ist ja eigentlich nicht so unbedingt, glaube ich, der Prozessor oder das bisschen Flash-Speicher da drin ist. Ich glaube, das teuerste ist ja das Display. Insofern wird das wahrscheinlich nicht so wahnsinnig viel günstiger werden als das Gerät nur für sich.
Ich kann mir das alles überhaupt nicht vorstellen, dass das überhaupt nennenswert billiger ist.
Also erstmal ist es ja noch kein Produkt.
Wir benutzen sogar denselben Font. Denen fällt einfach nichts anderes ein, als Jahre später dann einfach genau dasselbe zu machen oder zumindest etwas, was sie meinen, was irgendwie ähnlich ist, aber viel beschissener aussieht und in keiner Form konkurrenzfähig ist.
Ich hab mir so ein schönes Video angeguckt, wo jemand probiert, der Sascha Pallenberger, der hat dann einen dieser Mockups in der Hand und wie der dann probiert, das Telefon da hinten reinzukriegen bzw. wieder hinten rauszukriegen. Von diesem Pad-Phone. Und wirklich, er bricht sich dabei halb einen ab. Also ich meine, wenn ich so ein Mockup baue und damit auf eine Messe rumgehe und das muss nicht funktionieren, dann sorge ich doch wenigstens dafür, dass es leicht rein und rausgeht.
Aber es ist wahrscheinlich, hätte er die Zauberbewegungen vorher nicht gemacht, die man machen muss, um das Ding da rauszukriegen.
Und vor allen Dingen, bei dieser Präsentation, das Ding wurde ja von so einem Mitarbeiter reingeschoben. Das siehst du ja dann auch, wenn du ein paar Mal guckst, siehst du, wie dann jemand sozusagen dieses Pult da reinschiebt, geduckt und irgendwie seine komische Zaubergeste.
Der Typ hat nicht mal seinen Text auswendig gelernt gehabt. Das war echt hart.
Und wie er diese magische Geste macht, das passiert erstmal 5 Sekunden lang nicht.
Und er wird langsam nervös, bis dann irgendjemand hinten auf der Bühne so Aufwachen! Du sollst das nächste Slide machen! Und dann nimmt er das Telefon da raus, und dann klingelt das Telefon, er nimmt das hinten raus und sagt dann so viel Sand, ich weiß nicht, das hört man so kaum noch auf dem Video, Steve has to wait!
Das macht mich wirklich fassungslos, diese ganze... Haben die denn auch alle, ich meine, haben die keine Ehre? Oder haben die keine, ich weiß nicht, fühlen die sich nicht auch mal getrieben? Gibt es da keine 18-Jährigen, die der Welt noch mal was beweisen wollen? Sind das alles nur solche Tatakreise, die dann irgendwie 10 Jahre später dann auch mal verstanden haben, dass Apple mit ihrem Kurs dann wohl gerade doch mal zufällig ganz erfolgreich ist? Und dann kopieren sie da irgendwas, was sie so im Fernsehen gesehen haben auf YouTube?
Na, die 18-jährigen schreiben alle iPhone-Apps.
Die wahrscheinlich vergreisen einfach die ganzen anderen IT-Unternehmen von innen.
Ich kriege einfach keinen Nachschub mehr.
Ein Kumpel von mir, der arbeitet jetzt bei T-Systems, weiß ich auch, wo ich mich frage, was ihn da geritten hat, und der hat jetzt ein Dienst-Handy bekommen, ein Android, und dann wollte er mir das zeigen, so guck mal hier, Android, finde ich, habe ich ja noch nie vorher gehabt, das ist ja scheiße, und dann hat er keinen Datentarif dazu. Die Mitarbeiter von T-Systems kriegen keinen Datentarif zu ihrem Android-Telefon, weil es zu teuer ist.
Das ist jetzt aber auch wieder so ein bisschen Deutschland, oder?
Ich glaube, das ist eine große Firma. Das ist so dieses interne Geldgeschacher, die haben auch keine WLAN-Hotspots, sondern die haben nur diese Telekom-WLAN-Hotspots und die dürfen die dann alle nicht benutzen, weil die dann genauso bezahlen müssten, wie wenn wir uns jetzt in so einen WLAN-Hotspot von einer Telekom reinwählen. Das wäre dann irgendwie pro Nase 80 Euro im Monat und das will die Firma dann nicht und darum darfst du da keinen WLAN nutzen.
Also da paaren sich wirklich auch gerade die Debilen mit den Nutzlosen. Das ist wirklich unfassbar. Microsoft und Skype. Ja, gerade Skype. Dann kamen kaum WLANse irgendwie gekauft. Fängt dann irgendwie diese Software an. Irgendwelche ungefragte Software.
Das erste Mal, dass sie ausgefallen sind. Die haben erstmal ein Outage stehen gelegt. Ich frag mich mittlerweile, schaffen das? Ist das so, dass irgendjemand von Microsoft reinkommt und sagt, okay, jetzt feiern wir erstmal richtig schön. Hier, drück mal den Note aus. Oder ob die es gerade noch so mit Mühe und Not schaffen. Hey, guck mal, wir sind noch nicht abgestürzt.
Das wird wahrscheinlich Microsofts Klonen von Apples Reality-Distortion-Field.
Bei einmal kommt es rein, das Netzwerk fällt aus.
Genau, Microsoft Reality von Windows. Das übernimmt dann einfach diese ganzen gekauften Firmen automatisch und dann fangen die ganzen Mitarbeiter auch an, dummes Zeug zu reden und irgendwie an den falschen Knöpfen zu schrauben.
Das ist doch alles.
Das wird wirklich so ein Dreck.
Schämen sollten die sich, schämen. Das wird weder nichts, noch was. Schämt euch.
Das traurige ist halt, du hast recht.
So, wem wollen wir jetzt den Glaskugel machen?
Ich hoffe, HP sind, glaube ich, die Letzten, die noch eine Chance haben. Ich habe nicht viel Hoffnung, nicht viel, aber ein bisschen, ein bisschen habe ich noch.
Es muss doch noch irgendjemand einfallen, der vernünftige Hardware produziert zum Consumer-Bereich.
Trauen sich ja auch alle nix.
Ich meine, alleine diese 90er Jahre, das ist für diese ganze IT-Industrie eine verlorene Dekade. Erst mal keine nennenswerte Innovation, weil alles in diesem Windows-Müll feststeckt und dieser ganzen Vaporware-Ankündigung und alle stellen sofort ihre Produkte ein, wenn Microsoft nur sagt, dass sie irgendwas ankündigen.
Nee, das will ich jetzt nicht so sehen.
Ja, und keiner, aber alle haben aufgehört, Systemsoftware zu entwickeln. Und das ist das große Dilemma heute, dass sie alle dastehen, gerne Geräte bauen würden und keiner hat mehr Systemsoftware in der Hand. Also die nennenswert ausgebaut und aktuell wäre.
Aber die 90er Jahre waren sozusagen, wo sich diese Technologie verbracht hat, also da ist der Massenmarkt erobert worden. Das ist so Anfang der 90er Jahre noch total klein. Nische in den 90er Jahren, riesengroß, nicht mehr wegzudenken. Und jetzt kommen so die 2000er Jahre und jetzt machen wir das Ganze noch mal gut. Ist doch eigentlich, sofern würde ich jetzt nicht sagen, verloren Jahre.
Verloren für wen?
Für die Industrie.
Ja gut, die haben Geld verdient und jeder kauft.
Jeder hat auch eins. Es ist billig genug geworden, dass es jeder haben kann.
Aber was haben die Unternehmen für sich getan?
HP verkauft Windows.
Die haben alle nur für Microsoft gearbeitet eigentlich. Und HP verkauft halt Windows, alle machen Windows und jetzt stehen sie alle da, wieder Kaisers neue Kleider. Oh ja, wir würden ja jetzt auch gerne wieder innovative Geräte bauen, die mit Apple mithalten können. Aber hoppala, einmal gibt es nicht mehr die passende Systemssoftware dafür. Und ach ja, übrigens, wir sind ja HP, eine der ältesten Computerfirmen überhaupt. Früher haben wir alle möglichen Computer erfunden und diese ganze Betriebssystemsoftware haben wir auch dazu entwickelt. Und heute ist das einfach nur so eine Büchsen-Schieberbude geworden, die einfach nicht in der Lage ist, eigene Software zu machen. Das ist der Grund, warum ich diese Resthoffnung habe mit dem WebOS und HP.
Du meinst, da kommt auch mal so ein zarten Ingenieurgeist.
Ich glaube, irgendwas in mir will nicht glauben, dass das der Grund ist, aber etwas anderes in mir will das hoffen, dass da irgendjemand bei HP ist, der so ein bisschen Gründer-Thomas-Geruch noch mitbekommt und so dieses, das könnte unsere Chance sein.
Der nochmal in den Keller geht ohne dass er von Hewlett und Packard riecht.
Genau, ein bisschen ohne Schütteln. Und dann sozusagen auch den Kampf aufzunehmen und auch wirklich mal bereit zu sein, jetzt fünf Jahre lang durchzumarschieren. Ich glaube ernsthaft, die sind, ist so ein bisschen dahergesagt, was Steve gesagt hat hier mit iPhone und so weiter, wir sind irgendwie allen fünf Jahre voraus. Aber jetzt sind diese fünf Jahre, sind nächstes Jahr um. Und irgendwie so richtig nachhaltig, was passiert und angekündigt wird. Einzigen, die da mitgezogen haben, sind Google.
Erstaunlicherweise eine Firma, die überhaupt nichts mit dem ganzen Scheiß zu tun hat.
Genau, aber Google war jung genug und Google war offen genug und Google hat das Internet verstanden und überhaupt. Also Google ist überhaupt die einzige große Ausnahme, die man jetzt machen muss. Nur ich bezog mich ja jetzt auf diese ganzen alten IT-Klötze der 90er Jahre. Da gab es Google in dem Sinne ja noch gar nicht.
Na ja, wobei ich glaube, Microsoft hat auch die Fäden gut gesponnen. Wahrscheinlich, sobald sie da irgendwann gehört haben, dass da irgendjemand auch mal was eigenes machen will, sind sie da sofort reingegrätscht und haben das verhindert. Ich meine, habt ihr das gehört hier mit...
Haben sie aber auch alle einschüchtern lassen, außer Apple. Apple waren die einzigen, die halt gesagt haben, wir bleiben dabei.
Wer hat das jetzt ausgerechnet, irgendjemand hat das ausgerechnet, dass Microsoft mit Lizenzgebühren für Patente für Android mehr verdient, als mit Windows Phone 7?
Asymco.
Also sie verdienen an einer Windows Phone 7 Lizenzgebühr...
Also es sind keine verbürgten Zahlen.
Es sind so grobe Schätzungen.
Es lässt sich herleiten und klingt...
Aber es war nicht ein bisschen mehr. Es war nicht ein bisschen mehr, sondern es war so irgendwie das Dreifache.
Ja klar, ich meine, sie verkaufen ja auch fast nichts von dir.
Ich meine, wie tragisch muss das für eine Firma sein, wenn du mit dem Produkt deiner Konkurrenz mehr verdienst als mit dem eigenen Produkt.
Ja, und wie tragisch muss es für Google sein, dass sie eine Software kostenlos rausgeben, aber andere sollen noch dafür Geld zahlen müssen, dass sie das dürfen. Ja, gut, da sind wir mal so in dieser ganzen Chain, dieser Android-Chain, da hat man so ein kostenloses OS, was dann aber noch kostet. Also, ich weiß nicht, passt irgendwie alles nicht zusammen.
Von dem HP Touchpad habe ich heute noch mal ein Video gesehen, relativ aktuelles, das irgendwie da in Taipei, was ist ja diese Messe, die da gerade stattfindet, auf dem Sandisk-Stand rum, also Sandisk hier, diese SSD-Karte, ist einfach so eine Führung durch das User-Interface und man sieht, dass ein paar Apps deutlich weiter sind als auf den Geräten, die ich so gesehen habe. Man sieht allerdings auch, dass es an einigen Stellen deutlich ruckelt und dass der entsprechende Vorführer schon noch sehr, sehr deutliche Gesten machen muss, damit es funktioniert. Also auf die 1.0 kann man da glaube ich nicht allzu viel geben.
Soll das jetzt nicht in den nächsten Tagen released werden?
Ich habe irgendwas von 15. oder 16. Juni gehört. Also es ist nichts Offizielles, aber ja.
Von Blackberry fang ich jetzt gar nicht erst an. Aber wo wir jetzt gerade schon bei Google gelandet sind, da gab es ja Android auch so ein bisschen, Foo.
Die werden Foo. Welchen Foo meinst du jetzt?
Na ja, Security Lücken, da haben wir letztes Mal schon drüber gesprochen. Dann haben sie das irgendwie geschafft, das Server-seitig. Ich hab das letztes Mal schon besprochen, war das schon vorletztes Mal?
Ich weiß jetzt gerade gar nicht mehr.
Ich glaube, das ist geschafft.
Das letzte Mal haben wir es, glaub ich, nur erwähnt.
Genau.
Dass es da jetzt losgeht.
Ja.
Ich weiß nicht, hast du noch was, weil du hast hier so ein paar Notizen, ich hab ja gar keine richtige Lust über Android zu reden gerade.
Wir sollten lieber über Max reden.
Ja, wir sollten viel mehr über Max reden. Können wir doch mal machen und dann können wir das nachher noch ein bisschen über Android erzählen.
Vor allem, wir sollten jetzt mal hier das Krönungsthema langsam mal ins Allianz fassen.
Ja, aber sie haben uns ja auch eigentlich kaputt gemacht, ne? Da sagen die einfach von vornherein, was da annoucet wird. Ach, die haben...
Glaubste nicht?
Ich denke, dass sie das deshalb gemacht haben, damit einfach diese ganzen Diskussionen, ob nicht dann doch vielleicht irgendwie neues iPhone oder sonst irgendwas rauskommt. Und dann... Weil das Problem ist immer, wenn irgendwie alle immer so bis aufs letzte Hardware, kommt denn Hardware, kommt denn Hardware, Hardware. Wenn sie das spekulieren, dann hast du danach so... Enttäuschung, Apple hat keine Hardware vorgestellt. Das gab es ganz häufig. Und ich glaube, dass sie das damit jetzt einfach beenden wollten, weil jetzt redet keiner mehr darüber, ob es denn nicht irgendeine Hardware-Vorstellung gibt bei WVCC.
Das reden natürlich immer noch Leute darüber. Das sagen die doch nur, damit sie dann nochmal ihr One More Thing dort holen können.
Die Antwort aufs Phone, Pad, Padphone.
Sie können natürlich gerne mein neues MacBook Air vorstellen, da habe ich jetzt überhaupt gar kein Problem mit.
Ja, das will ich auch gerne. Das nächste MacBook Air hol ich mit.
Ich fühle mich schon wieder so im letzten Jahrtausend mit dem Gerät allein, weil ich weiß, dass das irgendwie... Also mittlerweile bei MacBook, da habe ich ja nur noch gegant, aber bei dem Air, da fiebere ich dem nächsten Release entgegen wie so ein 15-jähriger.
Na, es gibt doch ganz viele, die dem 13-Zoll MacBook Pro sehr entgegenführen, weil das ja gerade sozusagen weniger performant ist als das 13-Zoll MacBook Air. Also nee, es hat eine kleinere Auflösung, ne? Und sowieso so ein paar komische, das hat nur ein glossy Display und irgendwie noch zwei, drei andere komische Features, die es eigentlich so zu einem total unattraktiven Gerät machen. Ich glaube, die verkaufen da bestimmt gerade 13-Zoll MacBook Air mehr als 13-Zoll MacBook Pro.
Ich glaube, das war auch ihr Ziel.
Ja, das ist auch egal, aber er hat das halt CD-Laufwerk.
Und Firewire.
Ja, deswegen, also das R mit Thunderbolt, ich wiederhole mich.
Und größere SSD.
Ja, ja, sie können da einfach alles verbessern, schnellerer Professor und so weiter, das geht alles.
Und Tastatur hinter den Blumen, Leute.
Lasst uns mal ein bisschen hier in die Glaskugel schauen. Also nächste Woche ist WWDC. Wir sollten übrigens erwähnen, ob wir nicht in einer Woche schon wieder eine Sendung machen.
Damit du uns nicht bittest und so die Reiselbeeren wegsammelt.
Weißt du, dass es so viel Neues geben wird?
Wir können natürlich uns auch zurücklehnen und sagen, wir lassen erstmal den ganzen Rauch der WWDC komplett entschwinden und dann machen wir es halt die Woche danach. Das ist vielleicht auch okay.
Ja, dann hat man halt auch noch so ein bisschen Nachlese.
Darüber nachzudenken und du redest nicht so viel dummes Zeug.
Und hat halt ein bisschen was zu vergessen wieder und so.
Also was haben wir angenaunst? Lion, iOS und iCloud.
Aber iCloud, das ist, ich glaube, das ist das erste Mal, dass ich erlebe, dass ein Produkt, was es vorher noch gar nicht gab, so einfach so, das wird schon mal, und jeder weiß schon, was es ist. So, von der Theorie her.
Nee, überhaupt nicht.
Ich meine, die Android-Leute werden sich auch alle freuen, wenn sie plötzlich mal ein schnelles User-Interface haben und so und dann würden die auch nicht sagen, das wollen wir gar nicht, Apple hat das schon lange. Ich meine, man kann auch anerkennen, dass Android seine guten Seiten hat.
Es gibt ja, es gibt das ja im Ansatz, ich finde diese Auswahl an Malte und Viren auch für Android auch benannt wird. Öffnen das Dokument dem und dem OTI-Type in dem und dem Programm und so.
Nein, nicht für Dokumente.
Ja, das ist aber der Ansatz.
Das ist ja dieses Kontext-sensitive, nur eben derzeit existiert das nur so auf der Dateibasis und du sagst ja...
Text, Bilder, so quasi Clipboard-Ersatz.
Genau, gibt's auch glaube ich schon irgendwie. Ich hab bloß keine Ahnung, wie das heißt. Chemisch stört nicht so aus mit der API, aber der Herr wird ja demnächst berichten können, nicht wahr? Du steckst ja gerade deine, badest ja gerade deine Hände da drin.
Ich bade meine Hände da drin, genau. Ja, erzähl ich jetzt auch nochmal ein bisschen, dann freuen die sich bestimmt auch. Ich werde ab 01.08. bei NextBigSing arbeiten und ich werde iPhone-Developer werden.
Warst du so lange bei deinem Hammer, dass du drei Monate Kündigungsfrist hast oder was?
Nee, das ist halt ein total kleiner Laden. Das sind im Augenblick drei Gründer und die stellen jetzt zwei Leute ein.
Bisher sind es nur drei Gründer, jetzt wollen sie auch mal ein paar Programmierer ins Boot holen.
Die können das schon.
Sind die nicht die ganze Zeit mit Gründen beschäftigt?
Die sind die ganze Zeit mit Gründen beschäftigt. Das ist der Gernot, der Mr. Toto auf Twitter. Ulrich weiß ich nicht, ob der überhaupt einen Twitter-Namen hat und wenn, dann kenne ich ihn nicht. Und die machen zurzeit dieses Soundcloud ab, in erster Linie. Das jetzt bestimmt auch einige von euch kennen.
Da werden wir dann ja viel drüber hören.
Mal gucken, damit wir wahrscheinlich nicht so wahnsinnig viel zu tun haben. Erstmal, das heißt, Touch-Ui-Kit-Lernen, das ist so mein geheimes Projekt. Also dass ich jetzt erstmal anfange, dann iOS-Programmierung vernünftig zu lernen. Bisher kann ich das nämlich alles, nee, Objective-C, so richtig mit das volle Programm. Schaffen wir das jetzt schon ein bisschen? Hat mir so ein Büchlein da per Kindle gekauft, wo ich mir das alles draufbringe. Ist jetzt auch nicht so hart. Wobei ich, was? Soll ich hier mehr Tempo machen? War das die Geste dafür? Ja, also insofern werde ich darüber berichten können. Aber von Services habe ich da noch nix gelesen. Ach so, Notifications wären besser mit iOS 5. Das ist glaube ich schon mal gesetzt.
Genau. Denkst du, ja? Ich glaube auch. Ich glaube auch, jetzt ist es an der Zeit.
Wenn das Geschrei groß genug ist und lange anhaltend genug, dann bringen sie das auch. Man hat dann irgendwann so eine Selbstsicherheit entwickelt.
Sie können dieses Thema auch nicht so ewig lange verrotten lassen.
Ja, sie haben sich wahrscheinlich einfach jetzt sehr lange darüber Gedanken gemacht, wie sie es wirklich tun wollen. Weil das ist ja auch nicht ganz unproblematisch. Dieses Einblenden von Nachrichten in Programme, die gerade laufen.
Na, es ist ja viel mehr als nur das. Ich finde ja zum Beispiel auch bei diesen Notifications, die man so kriegt, man kann da auch kein Payload zum Beispiel dazu packen. Das heißt, ich kenne das auch so, wenn man so irgendwie, zum Beispiel WhatsApp, ich nutze hier dieses WhatsApp-Ding und ich sehe da eine Nachricht, ich sehe im Notification-Fenster, dass ich eine Nachricht habe und dann mache ich die auf und WhatsApp startet und dann muss WhatsApp sich erstmal verbinden wieder und muss, ah, ich habe da eine neue Nachricht für dich, die ich schon lange gesehen habe, aber vielleicht einfach nur nicht vollständig lesen konnte oder ich konnte das Bild nicht erkennen. Also so in diese Notifications muss da so ein gewisser Payload rein, das wird, da muss was besser werden. Ey, das sagen wir jetzt schon seit Alu-S4, dass es besser werden muss, das muss besser werden.
Na aber, wir können ja auch mal unsere Tipps abgeben. Also ich denke, es ist Zeit für Notifications, es ist Zeit auch generell über diesen Homescreen. Also es gibt ein Feature, wofür ich wirklich mein damaliges Nokia-Telefon noch heute loben würde, nämlich dass es schlicht und ergreifend in der Lage war, auf diesen ersten Screen, der kommt, wenn ich das Ding einschalte, mir einfach anzuzeigen, was meine nächsten zwei Termine sind. So einfach. Dass da einfach die Möglichkeit gab, zu sagen, dein nächster Task ist das und dein nächster Task ist das. Alle Informationen liegen vor, aber es gibt keine Möglichkeit, das in irgendeiner Form anzuzeigen.
Ich glaube, das kann auch jedes Betriebssystem außer iOS. Das ist wirklich...
Jedes.
Ja, stimmt. So ist das auf jeden Fall fertig.
Ich würde mir ja sowieso erwarten, dass bei...
Das will auch eigentlich jeder haben können.
Da sag ich jetzt mal ne Bold Prediction, die ich selber nicht glaube, die ich aber irgendwie auch ganz cool finden würde.
Bold Prediction? Oh Gott, haben wir überhaupt für sowas... Sind wir eigentlich über sowas...
Und zwar, ich glaube, dass von Apple noch mal eine Uhr kommt.
Warte mal, halt. Oh Gott, das ist...
Eine Armbanduhr.
Du warst zu schnell.
Ich war zu schnell? Ach du wolltest dir einen Bold Prediction einspielen?
Naja, erzähl doch erstmal über die Armbanduhr. Das war jetzt nicht so bold, wie ich dachte.
Ach so. Wie ich nicht so bold wie du dachte.
Ja, jetzt nicht gleich beleidigt sein.
Ich kann hier viel bolder als du.
Also, das ist ja, also erstens gibt's da schon so, Sony Ericsson hat schon so hässliche Armbanduhr, die man so als Bluetooth-Companion für Android haben kann und so was. Aber eigentlich, wenn man das vernünftig macht, wäre das glaube ich eine coole Sache, weil die Armbanduhr an sich ist ja nichts doofes. Man hat so ein Gerät am Arm und dann guckt man, man muss nur eine Handbewegung machen und schon hat man einen aktuellen Informationsstand. Bloß, dass diese Information halt extrem, extrem begrenzt war. Das war halt nur die Uhrzeit und da hat Microsoft mal dieses furchtbare Spot probiert und aber irgendwie mehr Informationen darauf zu kriegen und ein Notificationsystem zu machen, dass ich die iWatch oder wie auch immer, iTime, ach egal, irgendwas mit i auf jeden Fall vorne, dass ich die Apple-Uhr im iPod-Nano-Format quasi so als Armbanduhr mit mir rumschleppe, die die ganze Zeit Kontakt zu meinem iPhone hat, die eigentlich kein eigenes User-Interface hat, außer so absolut minimal, so irgendwie kann so, du kannst eine Nachricht wegswipeen oder so was. So ein bisschen, ja, in der Richtung.
Gibt es dann auch Notifications eigentlich in Lion?
Also du bist jetzt wirklich der Meinung, Apple bringt eine Armbanduhr raus? Ist das das, was du voraussagen möchtest?
Na es wird, ja, das ist, also wie gesagt, ich glaub selber nicht dran, aber irgendwie.
Apple bringt eine Armbanduhr raus!
Bolt wollte ich so fett, also nicht im Sinne von Zanderbolt, sondern...
Zander?
Also Bolt, halt wie fett, kursiv, underlined.
Aber gibt es eigentlich nichts anderes? Ich meine, es ist iOS 5, also es ist ja Major, Major Big Version, da wird da wohl noch ein bisschen mehr drin sein, aber es war Notifications.
Unser Blick ist getrübt durch die Cloud, durch die iCloud, wir können gar nicht mehr ganz klar schauen.
Also was gibt es denn für die Cloud auf dem iPhone, außer dass man jetzt die Spreadsheets gesynkt bekommt?
Also vorher sagen, was in iOS 5 noch generell kommt.
Was sind die knaller Features von iOS 5?
Also ich fände ja mal E-Mail-Verschlüsselung ganz geil, dass sie endlich mal S-Mime einbauen, das scheiß Teil. Ich verstehe nicht, warum... Weiß ich nicht. Ist doch alles da, müssen wir einschalten.
Also Steve Jobs soll es nicht vorne auf die Bühne stellen und würde sagen, tappen.
Ja vielleicht, aber was Max schon sagt, womit steht Steve auf der Bühne? Steve steht nicht mit S-Mime auf der Bühne.
Nein, das war jetzt auch nicht... Okay, du meinst, was sind die Keynote-heavy Big Points?
Was sind die Knaller? Womit sie alle jetzt mal wieder...
Gut, also iCloud generell ist überall drin. So, iTunes Major Änderung, irgendwie ist die Musik in einer Wolke, ob es nun gestreamt oder gesynkt kommt, ich sage eher gesynkt als gestreamt, aber ob es nun geschüttelt oder gerührt kommt, ist auch am Ende egal und ändert sich auch mal von James Bond zu James Bond. Dann generell, alle Programme können in Realtime aktualisieren und synken und so weiter, das nimmt auf jeden Fall schon mal eine Stunde ein. Da gibt es eine Menge zu zeigen, wenn sie es können, und dann haben sie eine Menge zu zeigen. Und dann iOS 5, was könnten sie noch vorhersagen? Also ehrlich gesagt, mir fehlt recht wenig. Diese Notifications, die sind auf der Bühne. Also wenn sie kommen, dann sind sie auf der Bühne. Weil dann sind sie irgendwie smart und nett und mit Bildchen und ein paar neue Gesten, womit man sie easy peasy zur Seite schieben kann. Und was weiß ich, du ziehst deinen Screen nach unten und hältst ihn so.
Gibt es vielleicht auch so was wie Fullscreen-Apps, die man dann auch so irgendwie wie offline und später so durchswipeen kann? Bei WebOS die Karten und so.
Na, das gibt es ja schon auf dem iPad. Es gibt ja diese...
Aber nicht Fullscreen-Apps. Also bei Lion kannst du ja die Apps auch richtig durchswipeen.
Gehen wir jetzt von iOS oder reden wir von Mac OS X?
Wir reden von iOS, aber beschreibe einen Feature, was es bei Lion gibt, aber bei iOS noch nicht.
Und was es bei iOS gibt, und ich kann es dir hier kurz zeigen, dass man nämlich, wenn man sich die entsprechende Developer-Feature freigeschaltet hat, dass man mit einer Vier-Finger-Geste oder einer Fünf-Finger-Geste, kann man dieses Menü hier unten anzeigen lassen, dieses Switch-Menü, was man sonst nur per Doppel-Click auf dem Home-Button kriegt. Du kannst zwischen Apps hin und her wechseln und du kannst mit dieser Geste, hier kommst du wieder auf so eine Zusammenfass-Geste, kommst du auf...
Ich das auch?
Nee, dafür musst du dein iPad für mit einem Developer-Account freischalten lassen. Und meine Vermutung zu dem Thema ist, dass sie einfach, sie haben das für Developer-Accounts gemacht, um klarzumachen, Leute, diese Gesten gehören uns. Ihr dürft die, sorgt dafür, dass eure Apps damit klarkommen. Weil demnächst wird das unsere Geste sein.
Also nächstes...
Es könnte aber auch sein, wir sind uns noch nicht ganz so sicher, ob das wirklich die Gesten sind, weil so richtig handlich finde ich sie nicht.
Nee, die sind noch nicht so super handlich. Das meine ich, also...
Aber keiner wird sie jetzt benutzen.
Aber es gibt...
Vier oder fünf Finger gehören uns und irgendwas denken wir uns damit aus, irgendwas Tolles.
Das predikte ich, denn es ist meine Bold Prediction, dass es Fullscreen Apps und Swipe Switching für iOS gibt. Nein, aber dass du halt die so Switch, also so einfach so wechseln kannst.
Meinst du, dass sie das bei default anscheiden?
Also weil, was mich halt, nein, also was, ja, was mich halt nervt, ist ja beim Upswitchen immer schon dieses Doppelklick auf den Home-Button und suchen und dann tap, also so richtig fluffig ist das Upswitchen immer noch nicht. Und das fände ich zum Beispiel bei den WebOS auch viel schicker. Dieses Kartenmodell, sodass du da so durchswipen und swuschen kannst, das fässt sich schon sehr fluffig an und ich glaube, da könnten sie vielleicht auch bei iOS 5 nochmal nachlegen, weil, also das Multitasking ist schon, so richtig wie Multitasking fühlt sich das halt nicht an.
Wobei, diese Variante hier vom iPad, das ist ja, da hat man ja nicht irgendein Zwischenscreen, in dem man irgendwas sieht oder sowas, wo man sozusagen wie bei WebOS hin und her wechselt und ich glaube, das wird der Weg, den Apple geht. Also es wird so sein, du hast eine Geste und schwupp, du bist im anderen Programm. Nicht so, du brauchst eine Geste, um in den Zwischenmodus zu kommen und dann brauchst du eine zweite Geste, um hin und her zu wechseln und dann musst du nochmal drauf tippen, damit du auch wirklich drin bist, sondern es wird wirklich so sein, mach eine Geste und du hast, bist beim vorherigen Programm. Ich glaube, sowas in der Richtung wird's werden und so ähnlich wie es im Augenblick ist, wird das auch sein, schätze ich mal, außer, dass es natürlich flüssiger ist und was bei dem hier extrem nervt, ist, man weiß nie zu welchem, also ich habe gerade ein Programm gestartet und es gibt halt nicht die Geste zum Zurückkommen, ich bin halt immer on top of the stack sozusagen und erst wenn ich dann, also das ist, es ist nicht so wie bei Apfel-Tapp, dass ich so zwischen offenen Systemen hin und her wechsle, also dass ich sehe, aha, das war eben gerade und jetzt kommt das, sondern es ist irgendwie...
Du siehst nur die Fenster und weißt nicht zu welchem Programm das Fenster gehört?
Du weißt nicht zu welchem Fenster Programm das gehört, du weißt aber auch nicht wirklich, wie viele Swipes du jetzt brauchst, um zwischen, um zum vorherigen Programm zurückzukommen. Das ist nicht immer so ganz klar und das werden sie noch alles ein bisschen hübscher machen müssen, aber das werden sie auf jeden Fall machen, da bin ich mir auch zumindest sicher.
Also haben wir jetzt für iOS alles Cloud oder was? Notifications und Multitasking Improvement und Dashboard und Max prediktet die Armbanduhr.
Genau und eine Armbanduhr, Eieruhr.
Gut, das heißt wir haben jetzt für Lion eigentlich ja schon alles für iOS.
Ein bisschen wenig für iOS.
Wir sollten uns noch was ausdenken, was Tim sich auf jeden Fall kauft, damit wir ihn beim nächsten Mal auslachen können. So wenn Tim dann so mit seiner Ei-Haarschleife hier rum sitzt und...
Nee, wieso? Also wie du schon sagtest, wenn sie da iCloud einbauen, dann werden drei Viertelstunde da alles sinken, was nicht bei Drei auf der Bäume ist. Bis hin zu wunderschönen iPhotos, slideshows und jetzt auch mit neuen Themes und neuen Musiken.
Einen Aspekt von iCloud haben wir so noch gar nicht benannt, weil ich meine, es wird auf jeden Fall auch interessant sein zu sehen, was für Web-Interfaces an dieser iCloud andocken können, beziehungsweise von vornherein irgendwie schon dabei sind, weil solche Funktionalitäten wie dieses iwork.com mit ich veröffentliche meine Dokumente oder ich veröffentliche meine Keynote-Präsentationen im Web, also auch dieses Verheiraten der Dokumente mit dem Web in irgendeiner Form, könnte meiner Meinung nach auch eine Rolle spielen. Und das auch nur die neue Version von genau diesem Scheiß ist, den sie da zeigen.
Und mal eben Fotos hochladen und so ein Kram und, das gibt es jetzt bei MobileMe schon, Web-Galerien und so. Also, dass du nicht so flickern musst, sondern...
Ja, aber das ist alles so unattraktiv und so kindisch und... Gut, es ist so für kleine Familien und Omas und so weiter, ist das irgendwie wahrscheinlich schon alles, was sie jemals brauchen. Aber, dass da jemals irgendwie Schnappatmung bekommen hätte wegen dieser Feature, ist das nicht im Ansatz, mit den Announcements von Hardware oder cooler Software von Apple zu vergleichen, was sie bisher im Web gemacht haben.
Was jetzt vor zwei Tagen irgendwie aufgekommen ist, dass Twitter einen eigenen Fotodienst startet.
Ja, genau, da gibt es auch dieses Gerücht, dass Twitter in iOS integriert wird. Ja, so in dem Maße, wie Facebook jetzt auch schon drin ist.
Facebook? Wo ist denn Facebook im iOS drin?
Ist Facebook nicht in iOS? Mal nachdenken. Nee, Facebook ist in iPhoto, oder?
In iPhoto ist es, ja, ja. Aber auf dem iPhone ist es, glaube ich, noch gar nicht präsent.
Aber YouTube ist halt.
YouTube, so wie man YouTube-Videos, also du meinst das?
Hochladen zu Vimeo, hochladen zu YouTube. Nee, das mit dem Vimeo war, glaube ich, auch nur ein iMovie. Aber du hast ja zumindest diese YouTube.
Du kannst auf dem iPhone, kannst du YouTube hochspielen.
YouTube spielt da schon eine besondere Rolle. Und hochladen ist halt auch mit dran.
Genau, das geht sogar sehr gut. Das hab ich schon mal einfach gemacht.
Und das könnte ich mir halt dann auch so für Fotosharing direkt zu Twitter und so, das kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen. Also das ist aber kein Big Deal.
Was das Lustige daran ist, dass dieses Fotofeature für Twitter hat Twitter gerade angekündigt, dass das jetzt in den nächsten Wochen kommt. Mal gucken, ob das Montag dann schon mit dabei ist auf der Bühne.
Ja, ob sie das so groß an der Bühne binden will. Also ob das so Keynote-Material ist, die auf der WWDC so groß interessiert. Ich meine, es ist natürlich jetzt keine Show, die sich nur an Developer richtet, aber es ist natürlich, es geht hier wirklich bei der Keynote, diesmal glaube ich mehr denn je, um die Kraft der zwei Herzen.
Die Kraft des Abschlechts.
Ja, sie wollen da wirklich diese Dualität Mac OS X und iOS voranbringen und sie wollen glaube ich auch, oder sie müssen auch die aufgekommenen Zweifel an der fortgeführten Existenz von Mac OS X irgendwie ausräumen oder zumindest klarifizieren. Und sicherlich ist iCloud so einer dieser Klebstoffe, für die die beiden auch näher zusammenbringen, aber die eben auch diese Diversifizierung weiter erlauben. Weil du arbeitest einfach anders mit einem Laptop und mit einem Desktop-Rechner, als du eben mit einem iDevice arbeitest. Und das wird auch einfach noch eine Weile so bleiben müssen.
Wird was Neues zu Facetime kommen?
Ja, ich finde es mal schön, wenn sie da mal seine Ankündigung in seiner Ankündigung mal wahrmachen würde und die Specs veröffentlichen würden und Facetime wirklich zum Standard machen. Weil da ist halt bisher noch wenig gekommen. Sie haben ja auf dem Slide schön gezeigt, auf was ist alles hübsches basiert, so diese ganzen Tunneling-Sachen und etc.
Aber bekommen ist nichts.
Ich finde es ja jetzt auch interessant, dass es hier vorinstalliert jetzt kommt, wenn man das mit der mitgelieferten System-CD installiert, muss man es gar nicht kaufen.
Ach, dann ist es dabei.
Da ist es dabei. Noble Gester.
Aus Steuergründen.
Facetime über 3G.
Trauen sie sich nicht.
Na, Apple wär das sicherlich recht, aber das ist halt so ihr Deal mit den Providern. Obwohl ich das sowieso nicht so richtig verstehe, aber die Provider haben ja auch ein bisschen unklare Ängste. Das ist ja auch Telefonieren. Facetime. Zumindest dieses Video-Telefonieren, von dem sie früher mal behauptet haben, das würde ja dann bald mal kommen und das würden irgendwann alle machen wollen. Was sich ja so nie eingestellt hat. Weil ich glaube, dass sie aber vor allem, was irgendwie Telefonieren heißt, Angst haben. Andererseits ist Facetime dann im Vergleich zu Skype, was jetzt auf 3G ja nun schon sehr auch seine Verbreitung findet. Eigentlich kein nennenswerter Konkurrent mehr, aber keine Ahnung, wie die das sehen. Das bestimmt sehr irrational, so im Gespräch mit Providern.
Ich glaube, Provider, die denken so sehr, was kommt da out of the box mit? Und wenn das auf dem Gerät vorinstalliert ist, so Skype, wenn man sich da irgendetwas runterladen kann.
Ich kenne auch Höllenschiss vor Apple, glaube ich, mittlerweile. Also ich glaube, dass denen klar ist, dass wenn irgendeiner in der Lage ist, ihren Status nachhaltig zu gefährden, dann ist es Apple.
Wer hat eigentlich keinen Höllenschiss vor Apple?
Das ist eine gute Frage, Max.
Ich glaube, da sind wirklich...
Och ich scheiß mir ab.
So, jetzt ist es raus. Im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes.
Ja, vielleicht sollten wir mal so kleine Kapitel-Töntchen machen, damit uns auch selber immer klar ist, wann ein Thema dann wirklich mal ausgefressen ist. Auch hier wieder der Aufruf an unsere Audio-Freunde da draußen. Falls ihr irgendwie coole Ideen habt für lustige Kapiteltrennerchen oder sonst irgendwie was bloß nicht so dick auftragen, lieber dezent und nett.
Nee, die müssen in dem...
Probier die alle aus.
In dem Graph da müssen die auch so richtig einen Peak machen, sonst siehst du doch gar nicht, dass es da ist.
In dem Graph?
Na, hier in deinem Spektrogramm in Ableton da, die Vane...
Ja, das kann ich mit MIDI machen, wenn ich das hier Tisschen drücke und per MIDI dann diesen Sound auslöse und so, dann ist das alles durchaus vorstellbar.
Aber das könntest du dir auch sparen, wenn da einfach so ein Peak drin ist, so wie jetzt bei diesem...
Du kannst einfach jedes Mal laut schreien.
Ja, das wird die Hörer voran.
Ein kleines Kolbschen.
Genau, mach mir das Kolbschen.
Ah, da kann noch ein schöner Vorschlag im Chat, dass man mit dem iPad telefonieren kann. Das wird auf gar keinen Fall kommen. Also ich glaube, wir können auch schon mal so ein paar Sachen sicher ausschließen.
Genau, der Chat kann ja auch mal hier mal ein bisschen glaskugeln. Wir müssen ja nicht nur wir uns hier rausziehen.
Aber hier so Facetiming, habt ihr denn mit dem iPad keine guten Erfahrungen jetzt mit front-facing Kamera und so?
Na ich hab, Tim hat das ja gar nicht.
Ich hab kein iPad 2.
Ich hab's einmal ausprobiert und es hat funktioniert so beim dritten Anlauf und dann hab ich ihn nie wieder gemacht.
Ich frag mich echt, warum das nicht mit iChat auf dem iPad geht, weil iChat, Videochat und Screen Sharing und so, das funktioniert so gut. Da ist Facetime echt ein Stinker dagegen und...
Ja, dass diese Dienste nicht irgendwie mehr miteinander verheiratet sind. Das ist alles so eine merkwürdige, absurde Quicksilsel, wobei ich mir auch durchaus vorstellen kann, dass das eben noch mal so ein nachhaltiger Development-Schritt ist. Und das könnte auch so sein. Aber ich erwarte jetzt eben nicht mehr so sehr viele neue Features in Line, sondern alles, was jetzt noch dazukommt, ist im Wesentlichen diese Cloud-Geschichte und dann natürlich tonnenweise Kleinigkeiten, die jetzt auch in den letzten Wochen und Monaten schon so hier und da zusammengetragen wurden. iChat, Facetime, andererseits ist auch so was, das kann auch außerhalb dieser US-Zyklen noch mal kommen.
Auf jeden Fall. At Apple, manchmal hab ich so das Gefühl, so eine komische Definition von AB-Testing. Wie die da immer so ihre Tests...
Also du rollst zwei Varianten aus und guckst dann, welche besser performt.
Also bei Amazon, wo so dann 50% der User ein anderes Checkout-Interface geben und dann gucken wir's. Und Apple hat irgendwie immer mal so eine komischen Krippel-Dinger nebenbei so am Laufen und irgendwann verschwinden sie oder werden noch mal gepimpt.
Ich glaube, das ist das, was du bei jeder anderen Firma ganz massiv hast, ist da taucht bei Apple auch hin und wieder mal auf. Also wir haben da konkurrierende Abteilungen, die eigentlich an einer sehr, sehr ähnlichen Sache sitzen und sich das dann gegenseitig nicht zukommen lassen und so was. Ich glaube, das sind so die Auswüchse davon, die es auch bei Apple gibt. Ich glaube, das haben sie weitgehend im Griff. Aber was bei IBM total normal ist, dass da drei Bereiche innerhalb der Firma arbeiten, die im Wesentlichen am selben Gerät entwickeln, ohne es zu wissen, das passiert auch bei Apple. Und ich glaube, bei Edge Hat.
Haben wir jetzt noch zum Thema WWDC und Glaskugel und Tralala und iCloud noch irgendwas nennenswertes beizutragen? Und können wir uns mal wieder in den Kleinigkeiten der Welt festbeißen?
Ja, ein bisschen Werbung vielleicht.
Ein bisschen Werbung?
Der Robert, von dem ich ja schon so oft sprach, ne?
Also der Robert, der jetzt auch nie war da.
Ich glaube, das ist ein Impersonator.
Ach hier wird noch nach NFC gefragt. Ja, NFC wird glaub ich nicht kommen. Irgendjemand meint, Apple muss NFC kontern. Ich weiß nicht, ob die das kontern müssen.
Also der Robert ist schon mal nicht der Robert. Und der Robert, den ich meine, der hat ja jetzt auch eine iPhone-Up-Release, ne? Für alle Freunde, die Redmine benutzen, für Projektmanagement, Ticket-Tracking und so weiter hat er jetzt. So was wie Trucknur in Kula. Da hat er eine Abführ gemacht, kannst du auf dem iPhone jetzt dein Redmine-Managen und Tickets anlegen und lesen und beantworten und so weiter. Heißt Redmine-App. Ist jetzt im Mic, kurz im iPhone-Store, iTunes-Store. Rufen sie jetzt an. Nee, da hat er jetzt ganz viel fleißig neben der Arbeit Blut und Wasser investiert. Und dann dachte ich mir, kann man nochmal erwähnen. Ja, ist auch ganz schön, habe ich schon benutzt.
Tracking-Software fürs? Also so ein Ticket-Ticketting-Client.
Na, hast du Track schon mal benutzt?
Nee, ich habe mit Jira jetzt längere Zeit Erfahrung gesammelt.
Also Redmine ist halt Wiki, Repository, Bug-Tracking.
Wo gibt es so viel Redmine?
Da gibt es nicht viele. Welches davon ist es denn? Die Redmine-App.
Genau, Redmine-App.
Ist aber auch mit Abstand die teuerste. Was kann sie denn dafür?
Mehr als alle anderen. Zusammen, genau. Die anderen, die haben da schon relativ einfach ihre Interfaces zusammengeschustert und die haben sich da schon so ein bisschen zusammengesetzt und ein bisschen...
Ist ja nur fürs iPhone.
Nur fürs iPhone, nicht mehr fürs iPad? Ich ziehe sofort alles zurück. Nein, die iPad-Version kommt bestimmt auch in Kürze.
Sieht nicht schlecht aus.
Ja, die haben sich schon weh gegeben. Ich war ja auch Beta-Tester, ne? Wurde mir auch mal wieder was zugetragen. Ja, das war's auch schon mit dem Werbebeitrag. Also alle kaufen, ja. Und fleißig Tickets feilen. Und dann, was ich jetzt hier irgendwie letztens mal wieder... Das hab ich hier bei Not Safe for Work, glaub ich, aufgeschnappt. Mit dem BlackVPN, als du das Holgie im Polen hattest. Oder neben Twitter war's. Hab ich jetzt mir auch mal geklickt. Und jetzt war der eine Monat, den ich mir geklickt hatte, vorbei. Und dann hab ich wieder mal geklickt. Und jetzt haben sie ihre Angebote so ein bisschen umgestellt. Jetzt kann man ja irgendwie alle vier Server von denen und so weiter benutzen und alles günstiger. Für alle, die jetzt nicht wissen, was das ist, wenn ihr bei YouTube landet und ihr könnt ein Video nicht sehen, weil es in eurem Land leider nicht verfügbar ist, dann könnt ihr schnell in 5 Minuten bei BlackVPN eure Kreditkartennummer abgeben, kriegt Anweisungen, was ihr mit eurem Betriebssystem anstellen müsst, um euch dann 5 Minuten später das YouTube-Video über einen US-amerikanischen Server anzugucken.
Wollen wir uns doch nicht einen Affiliate-Link für die reinpacken, weil dann gibt es, das habe ich bei Wirres mal gemacht, bei Felix Schwänzel, da kriegt man dann nämlich irgendwie, bezahlt man einen Monat und kriegt 3 Monate und der Affiliate-Link-Geber kriegt auch noch irgendwas dazu.
Ich habe auch, glaube ich, noch ein Referrer-Code übrig, da kriegt man das dann auch irgendwie mit einem Dollar billiger oder irgendwie sowas. Es ist halt ganz cool. Machen wir alles. Genau, also dieses Black-VPN funktioniert nicht.
Also es funktioniert ganz gut. Ich habe ja früher viel Swiss-VPN genommen, die wurden dann wahrscheinlich von irgendeiner Bude gekauft, die man wieder überhaupt keinen Verstand hatte und dann haben sie irgendwie es geschafft, einfach diese Webseite so dermaßen aus ihrer Company-Webseite herauszuhalten, dass man einfach keine Chance hatte, überhaupt noch diesen Dienst zu kaufen. Keine Ahnung, ob sie das wirklich ernst gemeint haben. Ansonsten kochen die alle eigentlich mit demselben Wasser. Das sind halt alles PPTP-basierte Dienste, was zwar jetzt kein besonders glorifiziertes Protokoll ist, aber den Vorteil hat, dass es halt eines derjenigen ist, die so im OST eingebaut sind und eben auch im iPhone. Dann geht das einfach mal ratze-fatze. Was ich nicht genau weiß bei BlackVPN, aber ich glaube, das habe ich auch ausprobiert, also inwieweit, wenn man jetzt einen Account kauft, mit wie viel Rechner man gleichzeitig unter diesem Account auch online sein kann, weil wenn ich sowas kaufe, dann will ich das auch gleich auf mein iPad, auf mein iPhone, auf meinen Mac haben und dann mit all denen dann auch darüber kommunizieren können, dass ich immer on-demand das Ganze habe. Das ist praktisch auf Konferenzen, wenn man einfach mal so die Fault-Verschlüsselung anschalten will, ist das praktisch für dieses in deinem Land nicht verfügbare Problem. Es ist begrenzt geeignet, muss man sagen, für so universitäre Umgebungen, die so paranoid sind und der Meinung ist, die Welt braucht nur Port 80 und Proxys. Wenn sie ganz hart drauf sind, da hab ich schon so einige erlebt, die ganz hart drauf sind, dann wird da aber auch wirklich alles geblockt, was auch nur in irgendeiner Form nach VPN aussieht, also diese Ports, dieser Protokoll-Typ in dem Fall, wird auch noch geblockt, das ist sogar ziemlich gängig. Es werden sogar die Websites, die VPN verkaufen. Du kannst also noch nicht mal in den Account klicken aus diesem Netz heraus, also wirklich richtig so Adolf-Mode on, ja? Und nichtsdestotrotz, diese Dienste sind relativ günstig und wenn iCloud nicht auch noch VPN mitbringt, dann kann man sich das irgendwie auch noch...
Ich benutze es ja auch statt PPTP, oder was heißt statt, aber ich benutze es halt über das OpenVPN mit Viscosity sogar. In meinem Fall, ich weiß gar nicht, ist das dann was anderes als PPTP?
Das ist OpenVPN, ne?
Und das ist dann was anderes als PPTP?
Protokoll-technisch und so weiter? Ja, das ist was ganz anderes, das benutzt auch normales IP, dieses PPTP, das benutzt noch mal so einen eigenen Protokoll-Type, das ist auch noch ein Problem. Viscosity hatten wir glaube ich schon mal besprochen, ne? Und ich bin mir jetzt gerade nicht so sicher, ob ich den schon mal ausprobiert habe. Das Problem, was ich bisher mit allen OpenVPN Clients hatte, und ich glaube da ist auch dieses Tool keine Ausnahme, aber wir wissen...
Das mit dem Nameserver.
Nee, nicht so sehr das mit dem Nameserver, sondern das mit der Interface Order. Das ist für mich eigentlich entscheidend. Also wenn ich einen VPN-Account einrichte, unter Meco S10, dann tue ich das, indem ich quasi als virtuelles Interface hinzufüge. Und dann kann ich diesem Interface einfach auch eine Order sagen. Das heißt, ich kann sagen, das geht jetzt vor allen anderen. Das heißt, wenn die VPN-Verbindung existiert, dann ist das, wo das alles durchgeroutet wird. Und damit stelle ich einerseits sicher, dass das mit meinen ganzen anderen Networksetups auch kompatibel ist und dass ich überhaupt flexibel dieses Routing definieren kann. Während OpenVPN meistens so unten auf Unix, layer, mit irgendwelchen Tunnel-Devices alles umgeht und diese komplette Network-Architektur ignoriert.
Aber wie kannst du denn die Order da definieren?
Im Netzwerk? Na, du gehst auf Network-Control-Pane und dann hast du da unten so dein Rädchen-Menü und dann wählst du aus Set Service Order. Dann kannst du da schön Dreck und Drop machen und genau sagen, was sehr wichtig ist in manchen Fällen. Gerade wenn du so Dial-Up-Sachen drin hast, wie eben VPN.
Dann kann man ja immer noch PPTP benutzen.
Zum Beispiel ist es für mich wichtig, klar zu sagen, ob jetzt WLAN oder Ethernet Priorität hat. Sodass ich quasi über das Ethernet lokal das schnelle Netz habe, aber mein Internet kommt über WLAN und vice versa. Es gibt alle diese Fälle. Aber jetzt keine Ahnung, wie das mit Viscosity ist.
Da kannst du jedenfalls nicht sagen, was jetzt wichtiger ist.
Er scheint das nicht als Interface dann irgendwie im...
Das ist hier wieder so...
Das verstehe ich nicht so richtig, warum das so schwierig ist, weil eigentlich so viele Tools das machen.
Ja, irgendwie kriegen sie scheinbar nicht dieses Tonnen-Device da so integriert.
Oder sie geben sich nicht genug Mühe. Das ist ein bisschen meine Vermutung.
Das ist doch da auch wiederum so, dass das, was da so unten drunter ist, das OpenVPN, dass das einmal irgendein Typ so gehackt hat, das Framework für Mac OS.
Aber OpenVPN ist auch nur ein Interface.
Ja, ich weiß.
Dann kann man das auch gleich als Interface implementieren.
Aber die Leute, die so was wie Tunnelblick und so weiter machen und Viscosity, die setzen sozusagen eine Stufe drüber auf, die wir benutzen.
Ja, aber dann müssen sie sich 1000 Control-Panels einfallen lassen, die diese ganze Funktionalität, die sowieso schon da ist, repliziert in irgendeiner Form. Und das halte ich einfach immer für Quatsch.
Das kann ich verstehen. Soweit funktioniert es aber trotzdem ganz super.
Also mit Viscosity bin ich auch... Ich musste mich mal in so ein OpenVPN-Metzwerk einbauen und hab dann irgendwie so mit Tunnelblick und wie sie nicht alle heißen, probiert das hinzukriegen und es hat dann nicht funktioniert. Und dann habe ich dann Probleme gehabt. Und irgendwie mit DNS, ich glaube, mit DNS hatte ich auch die großen Probleme. Genau, und dann habe ich diese Viscosity installiert, hab meine Zugangsdaten eingegeben und es hat funktioniert. Und das Programm kostet irgendwelche 7 Euro oder sowas. Und dann habe ich gedacht, hier, 7 Euro, bitte sehr.
Ja, bei S statt D, aber bei BlackVPN, die geben dir halt so Settings einmal für das PPTP und für OpenVPN. Und das kannst du dann halt auch bei Viscosity einfach so mit einem Klick. Also man kann halt OpenVPN oder Tunnelblick-Connections importieren automatisch. Das war bei BlackVPN ganz praktisch. Da musste ich mich sozusagen gar nicht um Setup kümmern von den ganzen Servern und welches Server und Blatt.
BlackVPN bietet auch OpenVPN an.
Du kannst dir halt so gleich bei Mac OS X Setup die Tunnelblick-Config runterladen und dann schiebst du die einfach in einen Viscosity rein. Und es geht direkt.
Piffig.
War schon... Schonjens Dufter ja.
Ja, im Bereich der Tools und nützlichen Dinger möchte ich zum wiederholten Male ein Programm erwähnen. Hatte ich das eigentlich letztes Mal schon? Oder hatte ich das letztes Mal schon? Jetzt bin ich mir gerade nicht so sicher. Das hatte ich glaube ich schon erwähnt. Aber ich wollte jetzt mal... Ah ja genau, ich wollte Subtitles machen. Und zwar zum Zwecke der Neuvertonung quasi so als Sprachvorgabe direkt ins Video einbauen. Und habe festgestellt, dass das letzte Mal für seine Kapiteleditierfunktionen schon so gelobte kostenlose Open Source Tool Sapler da auch ganz gute Dienste leistet. Wenn man nämlich Subtitle in diesem mehr oder weniger eins dieser De facto Formate, es gibt da mehrere, aber ich glaube das verbreitetste ist definitiv SRT. Das ist zwar als Format vollkommen hirntot, aber sehr verbreitet.
An der Stelle kann man da auch opensubtitles.org nochmal erwähnen.
Lass mich erstmal kurz erwähnen, was ich da rausgefunden habe. Ich musste Subtitles machen, habe dann festgestellt, dass wenn diese Subtitles als SRT vorliegen, dass man da so am meisten Erfolg hat. Und mit Zappler kann man halt jedem MP4-Dateich mal so eben so ein SRT da hinein importieren. Das heißt, du kannst mit Zappler einfach SRT aufmachen und dann hast du einfach einen korrekten MP4-Subtitle-Track. Also das Problem, wie kriege ich Subtitle in Filme rein, ist wieder mal einfacher geworden. Nun ist es aber häufig so, dass man ja noch ein bisschen dann rumfummeln muss. Dass man ja eigentlich sehr gerne so ein Programm hätte, was eben dieses spezielle Erstellen von Subtitles nochmal besonders einfach macht. Hab ich auch nochmal rumgeguckt, wie es da so aussieht. Und bin tatsächlich auf etwas gestoßen, was nicht total sackt. Also das meiste sackt total. Und das sackt so auf Anhieb nicht total. Bin mit dem Test noch nicht so ganz durch, aber es ist weit genug, dass ich das schon mal empfehlen kann. Und zwar heißt das i-Subtitle. Und das ist irgendwie so eine halbwegs korrekt programmierte CocoApp, die halt auch SRT lesen kann und einem so ein relativ brauchbares Interface bietet und die eben auch so mit Umlauten und sowas nicht gleich vollständig überfordert ist.
Nicht gleich vollständig überfordert?
Ich weiß. Außerdem... In Other News......gibt es eine neue Version von Miro. Ich hatte jetzt leider noch nicht so viel Gelegenheit, sie auch wirklich ausführlich zu testen, aber Miro 4 ist komplett überarbeitet worden und hat irgendwie alles komplett neu gemacht und anders gemacht und sieht jetzt irgendwie aus wie iTunes. Und bietet die Möglichkeit, wenn ich es richtig gelesen habe, ausprobiert habe ich das nicht, eben auch quasi als das iTunes von Android-Devices zu fungieren. Also wir wachen nochmal kurz auf und nehmen zur Kenntnis, Miro 4 ist da und sieht aus wie iTunes kann vieles von dem, was iTunes so auch kann. Und bringt eben jetzt auch Syncing mit rein.
Startet doch genauso langsam bei iTunes.
Also ich hab jetzt noch keine wirklichen intensiven Tests gefahren, aber das finde ich natürlich sehr interessant, weil das bedeutet, wenn man jetzt so ein Android-Device hat und Podcasting und runterladen ist ein Problem, könnte es sein, dass man mit Miro 4 gute Ergebnisse erzählt. Ich bin da mal ganz zurückhaltend, weil ich weiß nicht, ob das irgendwie alle Nasen lang crasht und ich hab auch keine Erfahrung damit, wie das Syncing funktioniert. An der Stelle wäre ich über Erfahrungsberichte in den Kommentaren im Übrigen auch sehr dankbar. Denn Miro hat ja gegenüber iTunes diesen kolossalen Vorteil, dass es eben auch mit bitteren Feats klarkommt. Und sollte sich eben Miro hier vielleicht als der Premiere-Podcast-Client für Android-Devices herausstellen, ist es auf einmal so, dass die Android-Infrastruktur hier eine Nasenlänge voraus ist gegenüber der iTunes-iPhone-iPod-Infrastruktur. Vielleicht sogar zwei Nasenlängen voraus.
Ich glaube nicht dran, ehrlich gesagt.
Woran glaubst du konkret nicht dran?
Dass die Android-Infrastruktur in der Hinsicht...
Im Bezug auf Podcasts. Ja, das ist nicht gut bei iPhone.
Aber bei Android ist es, wie ist es denn jetzt, ohne Miro?
Ohne Miro, es gibt halt keine Software, die ordentlich auf dem Desktop irgendwie Podcast-Vids runterlädt und auf dem Device draufsündigt. Aber es gibt Podcast-Clients auf Android.
Sogar von Google ein.
Gibt es aber auch einen mit BitTorrent?
BitTorrent hat er glaube ich nicht, der heißt Listen und das glaube ich so, wohl damals fand ich ihn total scheiße. Was er hat, was schönes, du kannst per Google-Reader, du legst dir in Google-Reader einen Listen-Ordner an und alles was da drin ist, geht automatisch, dann ist auch Listen auf dem Android-Gerät vorhanden und wenn du einen Podcast abonnieren willst, dann machst du das eben über deinen Google-Reader. Darüber hinaus war es mäßig.
Aber die Quintessenz ist sozusagen, Google hat bisher dieses Thema Podcasts noch gar nicht da so richtig selbst irgendwie, also ich meine, Apple sagt ja immerhin hier Podcasts cool und featuret das ja amtlich und so weiter.
Was Sie vergessen haben, Miro 4 ist auch ein Frontend für die Music Stores von Amazon und auch von Android Stores und so. Also es positioniert sich wirklich quasi als iTunes, das kann man jetzt gut finden und schlecht finden. Es ist halt schon immer drin, es ist so Video-Konvertierung etc. Sharing im Netzwerk, also es ist schon einiges drin. Also ich mag dieses Projekt eigentlich sehr gerne, auch weil die das mit den Podcasts einfach einen Zacken ernster nehmen.
Zumindest was so diesen bitteren Kram betrifft.
Was haben wir noch?
Was haben wir denn noch? Haben wir denn noch irgendwelche Tools? Habe ich noch irgendwelche Tools?
Ach, was habe ich noch für iOS 5-Wünsche?
Ah schön, genau, dann springen wir wenigstens wieder ein bisschen.
Extensions für Mobile Safari.
Bitte?
Oh, da bin ich mir nicht sicher.
Warum nicht?
Ich erwarte eigentlich schon lange, dass das in Mobile Me Einzug hält.
Also auf dem iPad würde das auf jeden Fall Sinn machen. Zumindest diese kleinen Kappeldinger.
Ja klar, das ist ja alles CSS, JavaScript und so weiter. Das ist alles schon da, aber bisher haben sie sich halt noch nicht in diese Richtung bewegt. Also es wäre auf jeden Fall ein Kracher, wenn man mal einen Adblocker hätte und so, ne?
Adblocker, One Password, ich hab hier ungefähr 80.000 Sachen, die ich gerne hätte. So diese ganzen Sharing-Sachen, so Pinboard und Read-It-Later.
Adblocker würde auch einfach so...
Würde dir schon reichen.
Würde schon Batterieleben sparen, diese ganzen animierten Dödel-Dödel.
Das iPhone 5, jetzt drei Tage Packet-Riehlaufzeit dank Adblocker. Dann könnte man auch endlich Flash nachinstallieren.
Ich bin gefragt worden, ich hatte neulich so einen kleinen Vortrag auf Der Republika gehalten. Und der war dann auch irgendwann mal im Netz. Musste dann allerdings erst mal audio-technisch etwas überarbeitet werden, wie auch immer. Da wurde ich dann gefragt, was ich denn für eine Remote in der Hand gehalten hätte für Präsentationen. Ich fühl mir auch oft, dass da etwas ist, worüber man durchaus mal ein bisschen reden könnte. Ich hab da mal alles mal ausprobiert. Also wer Vorträge hält oder... Was denn?
Ich guck nur, irgendwie hatte ich so ein Düsen-Triebwerk mit der Gründich im Ohr und das war glaube ich der Beamer in dem Fall, oder?
Ach, der Beamer? Ich glaube ja auch der Drobo, der ein bisschen atmet und der iMac.
Nee, mein Miro läuft hier gerade hoch. Ach du bist das, dein Laptop ist das? Ja, ja, der importiere Audio-Details und Bildmaterial.
Ach, da könnte ich dann gleich noch einen anderen Tipp, den ich hier habe, noch vorziehen. Nämlich, haben wir bestimmt schon mal erwähnt, aber wer das noch nicht kennt...
Ja, letzte Sendung erst glaube ich erst.
Was? Ice-Dead-Menus? Echt? Haben wir letzten Mal schon erwähnt?
Oder vorletzte, also sehr...
Kann man nicht häufig genug erwähnen. Ich merke jeden Tag immer wieder, wie großartig hilfreich dieses Tool ist und wohl programmiert und wohl gepflegt vor allem. Vor allem, wenn man so viele Kerne hat, dann merkt man überhaupt das erste Mal, wann die dann auch wirklich mal ausgenutzt werden.
SMC Fan Control, was ja Denis auch immer erwähnt hat, finde ich auch ganz gut. Ich mag ja Ice-Dead-Menus nicht, ist mir zu viel. Ich vermute, das ist der Grund, warum deine Rechner und Systeme so instabil sind. Das ist Ice-Dead-Menu. Es hängt sich überall rein und monitoriert.
Ice-Dead-Menu bin ich seit Jahren superglücklich mit.
Also das ist wirklich feine Software.
Ja, großartig.
Vor allem sowas von kompakt und übersichtlich. Wer sich schnell einen Überblick schaffen will, wie es dem System gerade so geht, weil man findet halt auch extrem gut die Bösewichte. Gerade dieses CPU-Teil, das ist für mich mal sehr wichtig. Irgendetwas dreht durch, klickst rein, siehst du sofort, was ist der Prozess, der hier irgendwie querschlägt etc. Also das ist schon ganz sinnvoll. Zurück zu diesem Präsenter. Also ich hab für Präsentationen verschiedene Sachen ausprobiert. Ich hab's mal mit der Apple Remote probiert, dieses Infrarot-Teil. Das taugt natürlich überhaupt nichts, weil Infrarot setzt immer so direkten Blickkontakt voraus und den hat man insbesondere in solchen Präsentationssystems Situationen sehr selten. Dann hab ich auch mal diese Keynote-Fernbedienung auf dem iPhone ausprobiert. Und es ist zwar irgendwie ganz okay, und du kannst da drauf gucken und siehst deine Note, sondern es ist auch besser geworden. Aber irgendwie ist so ein flaches Teil ohne richtige Klick-Sachen, wo du immer das Gefühl hast, du musst wissen, wohin du tappst, ist es irgendwie nicht. Was am besten funktioniert für mich bisher immer noch, sind so diese einfachen Klick-Devices, die einfach Next-Slide, Previous-Slide so drauf haben und die eben funkgebunden sind. Was ich verwende ist der Kensington Presenter. Das ist ein sehr einfaches Teil. Und wie so viele, einfach so ein kleiner schwarzer Handschmeichler mit irgendwie Knöpchen und Laserpointer mit drin. Und du hast dann eben so einen kleinen USB-Stecker da mit drin. Den kannst du da so reinschieben, drin parken, wenn du ihn transportierst und dann schiebst du dir halt einen USB-Port rein, dann ist das quasi wie so eine Tastatur. Und damit kannst du in der Regel out of the box, ohne irgendeinen Treiber-Installations-Fu, mal eben so eine Präsentation fernsteuern. Funktioniert dafür, dass es eigentlich nur so auf Tastaturbasis arbeitet, erstaunlich gut. Das ist vor allem geil, weil man das auch mal jedem so eben in die Hand drücken kann. So diese Sache hat jemand einen Präsenter ja hier zack reinstecken und schon kannst du deine Präsentation fernsteuern. Mit Laserpointeren arbeite ich eigentlich selten, aber schade jetzt auch nicht, dass es drin ist. Als ich das neulich auf Twitter etwas diskutierte, wurde ich dann allerdings noch auf so ein anderes Device von Logitech hingewiesen. Ich hab gerade festgestellt, dass ich mir jetzt diesen fucking Namen nicht gemerkt habe, aber die haben da so ein rechts unten Modell. Ah ja, genau. Logitech R800.
Warte mal, ich muss mal kurz schauen.
Genau, Logitech Professional Presenter R800. Erstens hat es einen grünen Laserpointer.
Ein grüner Laserpointer.
Das ist an sich erstmal genau das selbe Prinzip. Ist ein bisschen teurer. R800. Hat aber noch ein Display. Hat auch für mein Gefühl, ich hab mit dem Ding jetzt noch nicht gearbeitet, ich seh das halt nur so noch eine etwas sinnvollere Tastenanordnung. Also ist noch so ein bisschen handschmeichlerischer. Aber es ist ja sehr wichtig, dass du so ein Ding wirklich blind bedienen kannst und dich da nicht verklickst. Aber was ich besonders interessant finde, wir haben dem ganzen auch noch so ein LCD gespendiert, wo du vorher deine Zeit, die du hast, einstellen kannst. Und obwohl wir alle wissen, Keynote hat so ein Presentation-Screen und da zeigt er auch deine Zeit an, aber im Zweifelsfall hast du immer solche Präsentationssituationen, wo du dein Rechner auch überhaupt nicht mehr siehst, geschweige denn da auch nicht immer wieder hingucken möchtest, sondern du willst irgendwie mit dem Publikum da interagieren und mal eben so den Präsenter hochhalten und draufgucken mit einem verstohlenen Blick. Das ist sicherlich was ganz anderes als die ganze Zeit so auf dem Bildschirm zu starren und dann ist die Schrift wieder zu klein und du weißt gar nicht, was das alles bedeutet und da läuft so viel rum. Also das scheinen mir so die sinnvollsten Lösungen zu sein. Kann ich auf jeden Fall sehr empfehlen. Ich glaube, ich werde mir diesen R800 einfach mal kaufen aus Interesse.
Auf der Seite.
Das habe ich mich selber angeschärft.
Komm, du willst es doch, du brauchst es doch auch. Technischen Daten, das sind überhaupt keine technischen Daten, das steht einfach nur grüner Laserpointer. Wie viel Watt, Mann, wenn du technische Daten hast, dann klicken da Nerds drauf und wollen wissen, was Sache ist. Grüner Laserpointer.
Du, das ist hier Powerpoint Publikum, ne?
Reisee3 steht unter technischen Daten, wollt ihr mich verhalten?
Ein-
und Ausschalter, ganz wichtig.
Die gibt es auch als normalen Presenter und dann gibt es noch den Professional Presenter. Den gibt es dann auch wieder hier, auch in verschiedenen, da muss ich mir erstmal durch den Wald durchklicken. Ja, ich such die passenden Links raus, wisst ihr ja. Okay, den gibt es sozusagen auch nicht als Professional, dann ist er wohl vergleichbar mit dem von Kensenken. Der hat mich auf jeden Fall nicht im Stich gelassen, so viel kann ich schon mal sagen.
Ja.
Kann ich hier nochmal eine kleine Software-Empfehlung von mir geben?
Vielleicht? Nein! Verboten. Ausnahmsweise.
Was ich ja ganz großartig finde, ist grablin.com. Das ist so eine persönliche Suchmaschine. Grab, wie das Kommando-Zahlen-Tour. G-R-E-P.
L-I-N.
Punkt C-O-M.
The Power of Grab and the Power of Adlin.
Adlin? Ah, okay, ne, kenn ich nicht. Auf jeden Fall, also damit's Sinn macht, muss man einmal komplett die Hose runterlassen vor dem Dienst, weil der indiziert deine Mails, also Gmail-Account, du kannst den auf deinen Facebook-Account loslassen, Twitter, Dropbox, LinkedIn, Google-Kalender. Google Docs und Google Contexts, dann kann man das alles vernünftig durchsuchen. Und wofür ich das so ständig nutze, ist um... Mir fällt irgendwie ein, zum Beispiel jetzt dieses Zitat, was du vorhin gebracht hast mit der SSD, mir fiel ein, ich hab das irgendwo gelesen, ich wusste aber nicht mehr, ob's jetzt ein Reader war oder ein Twitter, und also hab ich kurz hier bei Grappland SSD eingegeben. Und da der wirklich schön alles durchsucht, was ich so jemals zu dem Thema geschrieben hatte, hat der dann auch sehr, sehr schnell die entsprechende...
Also was durchsucht der alles? Der sucht deine ganzen Document Stores, das heißt, du gibst den Zugriff auf alle Dokumente, der durchsucht deinen Blog, der durchsucht deinen Twitter Feed und so weiter.
Facebook, Mail, Google Reader, finde ich ganz spannend.
Du suchst dir den dann live und nimm nur die Search Results von Twitter oder speichert der den auf Zwischen?
Der indiziert das.
Der liest den die ganze Zeit und schreibt den auch weg und dann baut er auch noch einen Archiv, weil bei Twitter kann man nicht ewig zurücksuchen.
Genau, und der macht auch deine... Also ich weiß nicht, ob das ewig geht, wie lange das zurückgeht. Auf jeden Fall macht er auch die eigene Timeline. Also es ist nicht so, dass der nur meine Nachrichten veröffentlicht, sondern wenn man dieses Gefühl hat, ich hab's doch irgendwo gelesen, dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit ziemlich hoch, dass es in Grapplin auftaucht. Und das ist bei allen Privacy und was weiß ich was Bedenken, die man definitiv da haben kann und vielleicht auch haben sollte.
Aber das Video auf der Webseite lässt dich nur mit Flash abspielen.
Oh mein Gott! Deinen Daumen beschreibe ich ja hier. Ich fühle das auch mal phantomimisch vor. Ich mache jetzt mal so eine Suchbewegung.
Oh, Indiana Windetour unterwegs.
Genau, und dann... Ah, und jetzt hab ich's gefunden. Siehst du, wo hast du gar keinen Flash für? Kriegst du auch so.
Okay, das ist gut. Dann werde ich aber jetzt nur noch das Max-Plugin nehmen.
Verbraucht aber ein bisschen mehr Strom als Flash.
Oha, noch mehr Strom.
Ich fühle mich ja wirklich sehr gut mit meiner Entscheidung. Ich kann das echt jedem nur empfehlen.
Ist das jetzt so ein echt gut Füllen oder ist das so ein wie Zeugen Jehovas fühlen sich gut, dass sie diese Entscheidung getroffen haben, gut Füllen?
Na ja, das ist, wie soll ich sagen, so ein bisschen wie früher. Das Internet ändert sich jeden Tag. Also es kommt jeden Tag wieder irgendwas Neues dazu. Weil irgendjemand wieder irgendein Flash hat sein lassen.
In 5-6 Jahren wirst du das gleiche Internet haben, was wir jeden Tag auch haben.
Na meinst, verbraucht weniger Strom.
Das ist super.
Ich hab ja noch den Google Flash Player installiert. Und da kann ich dann immer hingehen, wenn es Not tut. Aber bei Default kriege ich halt den ganzen Mumpitz überhaupt nicht mehr angezeigt. Und ich sehe halt vor allem die ganzen Vorbacks. Also allein spiegel.de, so in den letzten Wochen, wie sich das so granular von Tag zu Tag verbessert hat. Bis hin zu geht jetzt.
Auch ohne, dass man irgendwelche Tricks sehr hat.
Ja, die wollen ja auch alle auf dem iPad funktionieren. Und das findet jetzt einfach statt.
Sehr schön.
Gretlin, das ist ja wirklich so das Post-Privacy-Tool der Wahl. Es liegt eh alles im Netz rum. Gib ihm.
Du nennst das Flash-Abspielgerät, ich nenne es den besseren Browser, oder den guten Browser. Ich mag Chrome nach wie vor sehr, sehr gerne.
Er ist manchmal extrem fix und manchmal geht da was besser. Manchmal geht es dem Safari besser. Das hält sich so ein bisschen die Waage, finde ich. Aber ich finde ihn furchtbar hässlich, diesen Chrome.
Das ist wirklich ugly.
Ich finde Chrome echt toll.
Das illustriert auch diesen Persönlichkeitsunterschied. Ich wollte jetzt hier auch gar keinen Pass aufmachen.
Ich wollte jetzt auch gar keine Diskussionen machen.
So wie es bei Ich Bin PC und Ich Bin Mac ist, ich bin Safari und ich bin Chrome. Es gibt ja auch Leute, die benutzen Firefox als primären Pause.
Und du nimmst EA9? Nein.
Max, ich sehe jetzt schon die neuen PC-Mac-Werbespots.
Und wer ist der PC und wer ist der Mac?
Hallo, ich bin Max. Hallo, ich bin ein Max.
Ich benutze ja die Nike Webkit.
Das müssen die Hörer entscheiden, wer was ist. Aber ich glaube, ich bin kein PC.
Möchtest du dann dieser, wie hieß der, Schauspieler sein?
Was?
Was mag ich denn sein?
Dieser Schauspieler? Nee, dieser Mann, der den Mac gespielt hat.
Justin irgendwas.
Der PC war ja der Lustige.
Jaja, du könntest ja Lustige sein.
Ich bin der Lustige mit WebM.
Bei mir hört keiner zu, wie auch im Chat festgestellt wird.
Dir hört keiner zu?
Weiß ich auch nicht. Hier, benutzt WebKit Builds. Siehst du, im Chat wird es doch wiederholt. Hat doch einmal zugehört. Da geht auch One Password. Ja, da geht auch One Password. Nightly WebKit Builds sind nämlich so rohloher, weil es ist nämlich viel schneller. Es ist auch schneller als die Chrome Builds. Also, ich weiß nicht, gibt es von Chrome Nightly Builds bestimmt?
Die liefern eine permanent neue Version aus, mittlerweile sind sie bei Version 12.
Also, du kannst Chrome Stable, Chrome, das ist sozusagen, das will man seine Oma installieren, dann gibt es Chrome Beta, das ist halt Beta-Version, Developer Builds und dann gibt es noch diese Canary, also Kanainvogel, weiß nicht wie das aussieht.
Das ist dann so der Stream, der deine DSL-Leitung über Tage hin komplett füllt, weil permanent neue Versionen kommen.
Das ist quasi zwischen Nightly und Developer-Version. Wir haben schon mal probiert, dass es funktioniert, aber eigentlich...
Aber Nightly ist ja gerade der aktuelle Repostand, nachdem die Tests gepasst haben.
Genau, das kann es natürlich auch Chromium Nightlys haben.
Ich will auch Ali's.
Das Problem ist, so schnell baut das Webkit leider nicht. Also nicht auf deinem Rechner. Sonst könntest du das ja selber stündlich auschecken. Aber ne, aber nichtsdestotrotz, zum Beispiel in Sachen Webgl, wo gerade noch die Kante brennt, nicht eine blutende Kante, sondern eine brennende Kante, da findet man mit dem Nightly-Webkit doch eine deutlich gesteigerte Performance vor. Oder was war das letzte, wo ich feststellte, dass der Chrome, also zumindest der Default-Chrome, noch gar nicht das aktuelle Webkit hat? Das waren irgendwelche CSS-3-Features. Ah, scrollen! Ich hab hier irgendwie so eine Matrix in HTML gemacht, und da hatten die Objekte in der Matrix einen Schlagschatten. Und in Chrome und allen Browsern ruckelt es, aber im Nightly-Webkit war das so fluffig, mit so wenigen Prozent CPU, wo alle anderen Browser irgendwie so... Also wenn man mal so schnell einen Browser will, ist Nightly-Webkit schon auch ganz cool. Also schnell im Sinne von aktuelle Features schnell implementiert.
Ja, ich nutze diese Chrome-Developer und hab immer noch den Canary rumfliegen. Was an diesem Canary ganz geil ist, das probiert jetzt Firefox gerade auch hinzukriegen. Die wollen ja auch auf diese schnellen Release-Zyklen wechseln.
Das ist auch hier schon in 5er, Alpha.
Genau, die wollen das jetzt genauso schnell machen, wie Chrome das macht. Hier alle 6 Wochen, glaube ich, einen neuen Release rausschmeißen.
Die Geschichte wiederholt sich auch.
Das erinnert mich so damals an dieses Netscape-Navigator und Internet-Explorer mit Webseiten, die dann irgendwie möchten, dass du einen Browser der 5er-Version verwendest. Und wo dann sozusagen die Versions... Alle sich genötigt fühlen, immer zur nächsten Version rüberzugehen, weil die Welt nur noch die Versionsnummern wahrgenommen hat, aber nicht auf welche Programme sie sich bezogen. Dann musst du so Internet-Explorer 5 und dann musst du das auch an Netscape-Navigator 5 geben.
Aber es gab nicht mal so ein Netscape-Navigator 5.
Was?
Na klar.
Den 5er ist ja nicht ausgelassen worden. Also sie haben Netscape 4 ewig lange drauf rumgehangen, dann gab's da irgendwie mal kurz... Also kann sein, dass es für drei Minuten mal eine 5 gab, aber das hat Jahre gedauert.
Ja, das ging dann halt irgendwie ratzefatzig.
Ich kann mich tatsächlich auch nur an 4 und 6 erinnern. Oder gab's 6?
Also einen 6 gab's dann wieder.
Es gibt sogar 7, 8.
Kann sein, dass es immer noch mal gibt.
Doch, 5 gibt's.
Ja, aber das war nie so richtig, ne?
Codename Gromit, Or Mozilla Classic. Ja, das war wahrscheinlich dann irgendwie...
Ja, auf jeden Fall will jetzt auch...
Achso, dann hier ist es Netscape Communicator.
Aber gab's den in der 5? Also ich weiß, dass es ewig lange die 4 gab, aber die 5, das war dann irgendwie...
hat doch die Wikipedia garantiert hier.
Übrigens, wo wir gerade mal in den Analien des Internets graben, es gibt im YouTube ein Video zu der Geschichte von Netscape, so eine Doku, wo sie auch gerade an diesem Schritt sind, als letzten Schritt der Verteidigung der alternativen Browser, wo sie dann den einzigen Schritt sehen, das zu Open-Sourcen. Und da sieht man halt in der Doku die Nerds bei Netscape und wie sie dann so den Plan machen, wie sie irgendwie versuchen, diese unmögliche Codebase...
Wie hieß denn dieses Video noch? Ich glaube, das hatte ich mir schon mal runtergelassen.
Ja, habe ich auch schon wieder vergessen.
Also laut Wikipedia gab es von Netscape Version 408. Die war von 1998. Und die nächste Version von Netscape Navigator, die es gab, war Version 9 vom 21. Februar 2008, ziemlich exakt 10 Jahre später.
Auf jeden Fall. Diese Code Rush-Doku, die war ganz cool irgendwie. Und dann habe ich letztens noch eine coole Doku gesehen, wieder auf YouTube oder wieder empfunden, die BBC-Doku History of the Computers oder so. Die ist schon relativ alt, aber das war die Doku, wo ich das erste Mal von Sketchpad gesehen habe. Diese Vector-Computer-Zeichen-Dings, das war aus den 60ern. Adam Kay hat es ja gar nicht gemacht, der fand es später nur cool und hat danach was Ähnliches gemacht. Ich glaube, genau. Und die Doku finde ich auch voll gut gelungen. Weil die fangen bei dieser BBC-Doku wirklich ganz, ganz früh im Urschleim an. Und kommen dann halt bis 90er, glaube ich. Und es gibt es halt auf YouTube in mehreren Teilen verstreut. Und kann man sich angucken, das ist echt total spannend für alle, die sich schon so generell einfach mit Computern beschäftigen. Ist ganz cool gemacht, diese. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie heißt die. Doch, ich glaube BBC und History of Computers oder so kann man da googeln. Ich kann das gleich auch nochmal hier. Sag mal, weil du vorhin, noch eine kleine Zwischenfrage, weil du vorhin meintest, Hitchhiker's Guide to the Galaxy Podcast oder Hörspiel. Hörspiel habe ich ja auch schon mal geguckt. Ich lese das jetzt gerade mal wieder. Aber irgendwie habe ich im iTunes-Store nur welche gefunden, die sich nicht so inspirierend anhörten.
Also da gibt es einen von den BBC.
Das war ja das, das gab es ja vor dem Buch. Also der Hitchhiker hat ja mal mit diesem Hörspiel begonnen. Und dann hat er daraus das Buch gemacht.
Ja, aber irgendwie fand ich diese Stimme von dem BBC-Hörspiel nicht so geil.
Du bist wahrscheinlich auch eh nicht so ein Hörspiel-Mensch, ne?
Doch, ich fand zum Beispiel Helge Schneiders Globus Day ein ganz großes Hörbuch.
Ganz großes Kino.
Das war wirklich sehr schön.
Wie? Globus Day, das ist wirklich, das ist einfach...
Ein Meisterwerk.
Das ist wirklich ein Meisterwerk. Ich meine, Helge Schneider ist sowieso ein Meisterwerk, aber dieses Globus Day ist wirklich großartig, wie er irgendwie auf dem Pol steht und irgendwie seinen Diskurs mit dem Eisbär führt und so. Ist einfach...
Also es macht auch echt schöne Bilder im Kopf, weil das dann abends im Einschlaf noch hört und so.
Das ist wirklich unser Weihnachtsgeschenktipp mitten im Sommer.
Da kannst du auch einen schönen Affiliate Link in den iTunes Store haben.
Hände rein!
Da klingelt die Kasse!
Wobei Amazon ist deutlich günstiger als bei iTunes.
Ach, du nur wieder? Okay, dann halt einen Amazon Affiliate Link. Auch noch dazu gibt es alles. Country und Western.
Whatever you want, ihr dürft auch die CD kaufen.
Genau, die Sendung heute heißt auch Global Perspective, ne, wie heißt das? Total Perspective Vortex. Diese Episode in dem Buch, also ich bin gerade bei dem zweiten Mal wieder, diese Episode finde ich auch so amüsant geschrieben und beschrieben.
Ach, die heißt so oder was?
Ne, das zweite Buch heißt ja This Restaurant at the End of the Universe und darin kommt aber der Total Perspective Vortex. Der erfunden wurde, um seine Frau zu erneuen. Ja, Hitchhiker's Guide to the Galaxy. Chat, Hand hoch, wer hat noch nicht gelesen? Wir schauen auf den Chat. Drei, zwei, eins, der Delay müsste jetzt vorüber sein.
Ich kann mir das gar nicht vorstellen, dass das irgendjemand nicht gelesen hat, der diese Sendung hört. Ist sie sicher, dass sie das richtig verstanden haben? Ich glaube, jetzt melden sich alle, die ihn gelesen haben.
Ja, ich glaube auch, dass sich alle, die melden, die sie gerade schon gelesen haben, ja. Ja, aber es gibt ganz viele, die nur Buch 1 gelesen haben. Ich hab auch Buch 2 dann irgendwann so mittendrin, oder nee, am Anfang bin ich mal hängen geblieben, aber jetzt lese ich es doch gerade nochmal wieder alles komplett durch. Das ist einfach total toll.
Es ist extrem amüsant. Und da stehen auch fast alle nennenswerten Wahrheiten, die man eigentlich so braucht, sind da irgendwie niedergeschrieben worden. Und den Rest liefert dann Helge Schneider.
Der Anhalter ist so eines dieser Dinger, ohne dass man die Welt wirklich versteht. Genauso wie man Star Wars gesehen hat.
Zumindest versteht man das Internet nicht sehr gut. Also es gibt einfach so ein paar Publikationen, die muss man eigentlich mal so drin haben, um einfach das Internet in all seinen Diskursen irgendwie nachvollziehen zu können.
Ja, und das Internet ist die Welt.
Was war da jetzt falsch dran?
Das war der Drama-Button.
Ja, das war so Drama-Button.
Was hättest du gerne gehabt?
So, irgendwas.
Was ist da eigentlich jetzt? Office-Base-Soundboards?
Werbung einspielen, oder was?
Was haben wir denn noch für Themen?
Wir haben noch einiges, hab ich vorhin gesehen.
Wirklich? Wir müssen auch mal trauen, dass die Sendung nicht zu lang wird, ne?
Seit wann müssen wir denn da drauf schauen?
Wir haben noch Zeit, morgen ist doch...
Morgen ist doch Feiertag. Das ist eben Vatertag.
Liegen doch ihr alle besoffen an der Ecke und hören nicht, wann der Podcast zu Ende ist.
Also wir hatten hier noch so wunderschöne Themen.
Oh, wir haben schon drei Stunden durch, Jungs. Aber ich muss morgen noch frisch und ausgeruht sein.
Damit du das Bier halten kannst, oder was?
Nee, ich...
damit ich auf die Karre ziehen kann.
Apple-Kernel-Team. Das fand ich jetzt sehr aufspannend. Hast du einen Stellengesuch für einen Apple-Kernel-Team-Praktikanten?
Ja, ich hab da so einen... ich glaub, das ist ein Informationsdurchstich.
Oh, ein Durchstich.
Ist aber ernst gemeint. Also falls irgendjemand von euch wirklich ein findiger x86-Hacker ist, und einfach mit Assembler Bescheid weiß...
Wie, du hast diese Zuschrift jetzt nicht irgendwie von der Apple-Seite geholt, sondern Apple ist auf dich zugekommen und hat gesagt, du bist jetzt inoffizieller Headhunter für Apple gerade.
Ich kann da jetzt nicht sehr spezifisch werden, aber das ist wahr. Ich verbürge mich zu 100 Prozent für die Korrektheit dieser Information, falls irgendjemand wirklich ein cooler x86-Hacker ist und er einfach mal Bock hat. Es gibt derzeit die Vakanz eines Praktikums. Es wendet sich primär an Studenten, was im wesentlichen Gründe in dieser Visa-Geschichte hat, weil du kannst mal nicht so eben so Arbeitsvisum bekommen, aber eben wenn du Student bist, dann im Rahmen eines solchen Praktikums ist das wohl kein Problem. Und es geht so um so x86-Bring-Up, was so viel heißt wie Maschinen zum Booten zu bekommen. Sozusagen so diese Urwahrmachung einer Systemlandschaft, wo man einfach noch wirklich so mit dem Prozessor auf der niedrigsten Ebene machen will. Also hier so PHP-Developer und so weiter, das ist nicht das, wovon ich rede, sondern ich rede von der anderen Seite, der Programmierergeraden, da wo es alles anfängt, wo die Bits quälend den Prozessor verlassen. Wer also da Stellschrauben bereit ist, sollen wir mal eine Mail schreiben.
Also wer Modern Operating Systems mit der Muttermilch aufgesogen hat, das Buch vom Tannenbaum und dann...
Ja, nee, ich meine, wer x86 kann, man muss jetzt kein ausgebildeter Informatiker sein, darum geht es nicht, sondern es geht darum, dass man Fähigkeiten hat und es ist ja auch ein Praktikum, es ist keine Job-Ausschreibung, aber es ist halt explizit das, wir reden von dem Apple-Könnel-Team, das hätte gerne einen.
Und die suchen jetzt aber auch in anderen Ländern?
Ich bin mir sicher, dass sie nicht nur mich gefragt haben, aber es gibt auch diese Möglichkeit.
Wir suchen Colonel-Praktikanten und fragen dich. Mensch, Mensch, hast du ja weit gebracht, dieser Mobile-Max-Podcast. Oder ist deine iTunes-Store-Seite die beliebteste Podcast-Seite aller Zeiten und sie haben erkannt, welche unglaubliche Relevanz du hast?
Das weiß ich nicht. Aber ich weiß, dass Leute verstanden haben, dass bei Mobile-Max Leute zu hören, die nicht nur Fanboys im eigentlichen Sinne sind, sondern die auch generell technischen Sachverstand mitbringen. Und das ist ja auch jetzt nur ein Versuch. Vielleicht finden sie ja auch niemand, vielleicht haben sie auch schon jemanden zu diesem Zeitpunkt. Ich weiß, dass die Suche gerade on ist. Und ich dachte, ich baue das einfach mal ein. Wer Bock hat auf ein cooles Praktikum.
Und natürlich in zweiter Zeit immer uns berichten.
Ja, genau. Fotos, Videos, Tagebuch, Zwitschern. Und ordentlich hier Infos quersticken, dass wir hier auch mit heißen Firsts auflaufen können. Wir gerade dabei sind, hier nach Köpfen zu fahnden. Ich bräuchte für ein anderes Projekt auch nochmal einen Hacker in richtigen. Einen, der sich vielleicht so ein bisschen mit so Performanten Key Value Store, NoSQL-Geschichten auskennt. Also so Datenbanken, wo man massiv viel Daten reinkippen kann, um sie dann zu mappen und zu reducen. Genau, um sie ein bisschen zu mappen und zu reducen und schnell in lustige kleine Grafiken zu übersetzen. So ein bisschen mal Lokfallanalyse von Podcasts und Streams Sachen zu machen. Da läuft gerade so ein kleineres Projekt und da gibt es eine dringende Vakanz. Und wer da sich auskennt, insbesondere wer mit MongoDB Erfahrungen hat oder vielleicht auch mit Redis und der sich vor solchen Datenmengen nicht scheut und vielleicht auch noch etwas Erfahrung mit Rails mitbringt, das wäre ganz nett. Das wäre sozusagen die ideale Kombination, weil es gibt da sozusagen schon ein System, was weiterentwickelt werden müsste, das fängt nicht bei Null an. Das hat seine Vor- und Nachteile, aber vor allem Vorteile. Und auch da bin ich der richtige Ansprechpartner. Hab ich auch in meinen Blog geschrieben. Alterlan, ey. So, was hab ich noch ausprobiert? Ich hab heute was noch installiert. Und mal ausprobiert. Ich hab noch nicht viel Erfahrung damit gesammelt. Aber kennt ihr Mumble? Wirklich?
Passt das?
Mumble ist so eine Open Source Software, die quasi so Audio-Chat im Netz ist. Das wird halt vor allem von Gamern so benutzt, so, weißt du so, aller Counter-Strike, wo du halt da in so einen Audio-Chat-Room reingehst und Teamspeak-Style und dann miteinander schnacken kannst. Aber das ist halt so eine Open Source-Geschichte. Da gibt es auch auf dem Mac so, naja, also, das User-Interface reden wir am besten mal nicht so richtig drüber, ist halt so, wie man das so kennt. Aber immerhin funktioniert es und es kommuniziert so mit dem Meco S10 auf der richtigen Ebene, mit dem ganzen Audiokram. Und ich hab so ein bisschen ausprobiert und naja, also, es klingt an sich ganz gut, ja, das nutzt wohl vor allem diesen Zelt-Codec und macht schon bei irrsinnig niedrigen Bitraten ganz ordentliche Sprachkommunikation. Also es wird dich jetzt auf Sprache optimiert und man nutzt Server-Infrastruktur, das heißt, du musst so einen Murmur-Server aufsetzen, davon gibt es auch viele offene und du kannst natürlich auch deinen eigenen fahren und den irgendwie offen oder zu machen, wie du möchtest. Dann kannst du innerhalb dieses Servers so Chatrooms anlegen, ich weiß nicht, ob die so heißen, aber quasi so eine hierarchische Nummer wieder und dann kannst du dann eben diesen entsprechenden Raum joinen und jeder, der so drin ist, mit dem redest du dann halt. Latenzmäßig habe ich jetzt so in meinen Tests nichts unter 400 Millisekunden hinbekommen. One Trip. Nee, warte mal. 400 Millisekunden ist ja schon relativ viel. Ja, es ist relativ viel. Das stimmt. Aber es hat halt auch ein paar ganz nette Features. Zum Beispiel kannst du eben auch mehr Spur-Recording machen automatisch. Das heißt, manche verwenden das auch so zum Gruppen-Chat-Podcasting. Dass du einfach so einen Mumble-Server aufmachst, jeder schnackt lokal in seinen Mumble rein und im Mumble-Server läuft das irgendwie alles zusammen. Ich habe noch nicht so ganz verstanden, ob man nur im Client oder nur im Server aufnehmen kann. Ich glaube, man kann eben Client aufnehmen und du kriegst dann quasi trotz dieses Servers dann jedes Audiosignal separat. Du kannst dann auch so ein Multi-Channel-Recording machen. Also es ist auf jeden Fall ganz interessant. Läuft im Wesentlichen auch in der Mikro S10, aber eben nicht nur. Und vielleicht gibt es da auch ein paar interessante Kommentare dazu. Ich bin so ein bisschen überlegen, ob man das mal für irgendwas testweise so verwendet, aber ehrlich gesagt ist mir noch nichts Gutes eingefallen. Wofür? Wäre mal so ein interessantes Call-In-Experiment, aber ich glaube, das könnte auch schnell überhand nehmen, wenn alle durcheinander quatschen. Das machen wir ja hier schon ausreichend.
Heute kam ja eine neue Postbox Beta 2.5, und jetzt haben sie irgendwie... Wie nennt man diesen View hier, Tim? Das ist wie bei dem neuen Apple Mail, das ist so ein Nebenname.
Ja, weiß ich gar nicht, wie man das nennt.
Also so Column View, oder? Also es sind jetzt so drei vertikale Views.
Ich würde das nicht Column View nennen, weil Column View ist ja so dieses mit dieser horizontalen Navigation. Keine Ahnung, wie nennt man das?
Also wenn das jetzt so vertikal gesplittet ist?
Wide-Screen-View. Ja, ich setze einfach mal.
Ich bin ja nach wie vor mit diesem Postbox durchaus zufrieden. Das hab ich noch nicht ausprobiert. Ich hab halt wirklich so ein relativ komplexes Mail-Setup. Postbox war bisher das einzige Programm, das damit umgehen konnte.
Okay, ich hab ein total simples Mail-Setup. Ich hatte bis vor kurzem jetzt einen Mail-Account, jetzt sind es wieder zwei, die beide bei Google liegen. Immer nur beim Google. Jetzt wird es noch besser. Facebook-Integration haben sie jetzt seit der neuesten Version drin. Was ganz praktisch ist, wenn man nämlich, zum Beispiel wenn jetzt der Tim mir eine Mail schreibt, dann sehe ich in der Mail-Liste, sehe ich noch das Facebook-Bildchen vom Tim daneben stehen, sodass man immer relativ schnell erkennt, wer ihm da geschrieben hat. Und ich bin davon immer begeisterter. Die kriegen das relativ gut auf die Reihe. Die machen so wie bei Gmail auch, wenn du eine Nachricht aus einem Thread anklickst, dann sind auch die anderen Nachrichten automatisch mitgeöffnet, sodass man immer den Verlauf mitsehen kann. Man sieht aus den zitierten Stellen...
Auch die eigenen Nachrichten, die man gesendet hat?
Ja, genau, natürlich. Das macht Postbox auch. Und dann so Sachen wie, dass es Teile der Mail, die sich wiederholen, auch einfach ausblendet. Also wenn so ein Full-Quote drunter ist, dann erscheint das auch alles nicht. Das ist so...
Also das macht Postbox tatsächlich auch so, mit diesem Gesprächsverlaufen und den die Quotes bei Bedarf mal noch einblenden und so. Ich hab halt viel Mail und viele unterschiedliche Accounts. Und das irgendwie... Ja, dann lösche die Präferenz. Bestimmt. Aber dann musst du halt deine Mail nochmal neu, deine Accounts nochmal neu set-upen. Das ist halt der Pain. Also ich hab mir das ja vor Ewigkeiten mal gekauft. Bisher nicht, aber ich hab auch 30 Euro oder sowas. Ich glaube. Also Sparrow sieht halt bestimmt hübscher aus noch, aber wie gesagt, für komplexere Mail-Set-ups ist das schon okay. 29,95 USD gerade.
Gibt's nicht im App-Store?
Nee, im App-Store gibt's ja so einiges nicht.
Aber im App-Store gibt's ja jetzt auch schon so einiges, ne?
Ja, aber es gibt auch so totale Nieten, finde ich. Ich hab mir Alfred, der diesen App-Launcher, jetzt mal runtergeladen aus dem Mac App-Store, weil da ist ja gratis. Und aus Launchbar bin ich ja dieses Multiple Clipboard, also dieses Clipboard History Feature sehr gewöhnt. Ja, das ist großartig, nie wieder ohne. Und bei Alfred muss man aber das Power Pack dazu kaufen. Aber das Power Pack kannst du nur dazu kaufen, wenn du die Alfred-Version hast, die nicht aus dem Mac App-Store kommt. Also mit der funktioniert das nicht, sondern du musst es von der Webseite nochmal runterladen. Ja, sowas in der Art, genau. Und da dachte ich mir schon wieder Zonk. Und sowas wie Launchbar, Little Snitch und so andere Dinge, die gibt es da halt alle nicht.
Das ist ja auch klar, weil derzeit solche Programme auch überhaupt nicht die Zulassungsbedingungen haben. Launchbar könnte da eigentlich sein. Bei Launchbar verstehe ich so einiges nicht. Warum die zum Beispiel diesen... Warum die immer noch kein ordentliches Software-Update drin haben, wie alle anderen.
Aber das ist ja bei Little Snitch genau. Also das ist ja bei allen diesen Opt-Dev.
Ja, das Opt-Dev scheint irgendwie da noch nicht so richtig. Warum die das nicht verstehen, oder warum die das nicht mögen. Ich halte das für einen Fehler.
Ich finde bei Launchbar nervig. Ich habe irgendwann mal meine Seriennummer verloren. Die ist jetzt zwar noch im Programm drin, aber ich habe die nicht mehr so separat rumliegen. Und ich wollte irgendwann mal auf einem zweiten Mac einfach mein Launchbar autorisieren. Und habe die noch mal gefragt, wie sieht denn das aus? Finde ich meine Seriennummer nicht mehr? Haben die gesagt, ja, muss ich an den Zahlungsprovider, über den ich damals bezahlt habe, was ich natürlich nicht mehr wusste, über welchen Zahlungsprovider ich bezahlt habe. Und dann habe ich mich an den gewandt, habe aber nie eine Mail-Antwort gekriegt. Warum dann nicht einfach so, hey, hier hast du deine Seriennummer nochmal, viel Spaß, danke für den Kauf nochmal.
Die sind stehen geblieben irgendwo. Alfred benutze ich jetzt auch gerade so ein bisschen. Das fühlt sich so weit erstmal ganz fluffig an.
Ja, aber was kann es denn, was Launchbar nicht kann?
Nee, es kann eigentlich alles, was Launchbar kann.
Ja, aber was kann es, was Launchbar nicht kann?
Soll ich selber updaten?
Es kann alles, was Launchbar kann.
Es kann zumindest das, was ich von Launchbar benutze.
Mit URLs zusammenbauen und so? Jetzt wird es mal hier für den Drama-Button Zeit.
Nee, auch mit URLs zusammenbauen und so? Weiß ich nicht. Das benutze ich ein paar hundertmal am Tag.
Was ist ein URL-Zusammenbauen?
Ich gebe zwei Buchstaben ein, was weiß ich, so de für deutsche Wikipedia, drücke space, ich gebe da einen Slammer ein, und er baut mir einen URL mit einem Smashtest.
Das können so eigentlich alle, oder?
Weiß ich nicht. Das konnten auch einige nicht so.
Von den Features her ist das sehr nah dran an Launchbar. Ich habe jetzt tatsächlich...
Was ich sehr ausgefeilt finde an Launchbar, ist einfach so diese Gewichtung.
Aber ich finde, das kriegt Alfred fast echt noch besser hin.
Jetzt lädt sich Tim das runter, dann wird er dir mal sagen, was er kann.
Ja, das ist ja okay. Das wollen noch die Hörer. Die wollen noch eine kritische Auseinandersetzung mit denen. Nur weil ich sage, Alfred ist cool, die kriegen jetzt auch nochmal den timschen Kritikblick.
Alfred kann sogar SYNKen via iDisk und Dropbox.
Das ist übrigens etwas, was auch launchbar ist. Du willst deinen Launchbar, da sind wir wieder bei der iCloud. Du willst einfach dieses, deine Settings und deinen ganzen Ist-Zustand, das Willen möchtest du einfach übertragen. Ich möchte hier so ein neues URL-Template eingeben und dann möchte ich das auf allen meinen Rechnern haben. Daran habe ich mich wirklich so gewohnt mit Mobile Me, dass zum Beispiel alles, was ich im Safari mit Bookmarks mache, dass das einfach auf allen Geräten da ist, sofort. Das will man einfach. Program-State muss auf Wunsch beliebig sharebar sein. Wissen Sie, das kriegt er oder verteilbar, sharen.
Im Chat wird übrigens gerade behauptet, dass Little Snitch und Auto Launchbar in den Betas jetzt auch dann... Quatsch, ein Auto-Update kriegen.
Haben Sie es endlich eingebaut?
Wobei ich das jetzt hier spontan... kann, obwohl doch automatic... Software Updates to check, download and install, okay. Turned off by default?
Naja, er hat mir bisher auch immer gesagt, dass es eine neue Version gibt, aber dann musste ich sie von Hand runterladen und das Programm beenden und drüber drängen und scheißen. Also ich meine, das Software Update hat einfach anders zu funktionieren.
Naja, wie gesagt, ich probiere jetzt Alfred immer aus. Ich würde jetzt noch nicht eine ungeingeschränkte Empfehlung aussprechen, weil ich es noch nicht lange genug benutzt habe, aber soweit hat es mich noch nicht verändert.
Ich habe gesehen, dass darüber viel diskutiert wurde, aber ich hatte irgendwie noch keine Zeit, mir das anzuschauen, aber ich mach das jetzt mal.
Ja, wie gesagt, für mich sind die Opt-Dev-Leute einfach zu wenig vorne dran an der Kante.
Na gut, aber ich meine, das haben sie auch bei wirklich Konkurrenz. Erst mit diesem Hands-Off, ein Viertelsnitch. Und Launchbar gegen Alfred. Schalten sie auch das nächste Mal ein, wenn wir uns dazu eine Meinung gebildet haben.
Hast du das Powerpack gekauft für Alfred?
Ja, weil ich brauchte ja die Clipboard History. Und das Coole ist, dass bei Alfred, wenn ich das richtig gesehen habe, kannst du halt einstellen, dass ja zum Beispiel Passwörter, die aus der Keychain kopiert wurden, ignoriert werden. Also die landen nicht in der History. Und das kannst du bei Launchbar zum Beispiel nicht einstellen. Da merkt man zumindest, dass sie schonmal ordentlich mitgedacht haben. Also wenn du Passwörter aus deiner Keychain kopierst, dass die nicht in der History landen.
Das ist sehr schlau.
Also es ist eine Checkbox, die du anwählen kannst, aber die haben mitgedacht, hat mir das so gezeigt. Weil ist natürlich klar, wenn du da in Screen locks und immer aufpasst, ist das ja eigentlich...
Die können ja auch nicht alle Programme kennen, aus denen ich mir Passwörter rauskoppiere.
Nee, das nicht. Also ich weiß nicht, vielleicht ist sogar One Password Honor dabei, aber fand ich irgendwie ganz schön. Und du hast auch Snippets und so. Du kannst dir halt auch dein... Aber es hat Launchpad, glaube ich, auch, ne? Auch Passwörter aus One Password. Achso, nee, wird gefragt. Ich guck noch mal einen Moment. Ja, Snippets gibt es halt auch in diesem Alphard.
Okay, also 5 Weilen später macht wohl richtiges Updaten, aber mit ohne Sparkle. Na gut. Hat aber echt lange gedauert. Wie lange gab's Sparkle jetzt?
Ja, 5 Jahre, 6 Jahre, 7 Jahre, irgendwie sowas. Guck doch mal in der Wikipedia in der Englischen. Wie lange gibt's Launchbar? Gibt's, aber weißt du, was es in Alphard gibt? Da gibt's System Commands wie zum Beispiel Lock, Restart und so weiter. Da kannst du dann hier in deinem Alphard Lock eintippen und dann lockt er hier halt dein Screen, da musst du nicht so oben in das Menü über der Keychain klicken und so weiter. Also dann macht er hier so, wenn du dein Passwort eintippst, dann bist du hier gleich wieder check drin. Und kannst halt hier so locken.
Ich glaube, das gibt's aber auch bei Launchbar, dass du so ein paar Systemdienste hast.
Tippst halt hier so lock ein und machst Enter und dann macht er so check aus. Sonst musst du hier über Keychain, hier oben den System-Icon und dann mit der Maus auf Lock.
Kannst auch Screensaver eintippen und dann macht er einen Screensaver.
Ist irgendwie ganz schnuffig, dieses Alfred.
Sparker gibt's seit 2006. 5 Jahre.
War ja mein erster Tipp gar nicht so schlecht.
So Leute, die Sendung wird langsam etwas, ich würde sagen, sie dehnt sich. Wir haben jetzt einige Themen auch außen vor gelassen.
Welche denn?
Weiß nicht, hier diese Patentstreit-Geschichte, aber das ist vielleicht auch irgendwie echt keine News. Ansonsten haben wir vielleicht auch alles.
Geil, da hat jemand im Chat die Lösung. Shift, Control, Eject, das ist ja das, wonach ich bestimmt 2 oder 3 oder 4 Jahre gesucht hab.
Was? Shift?
Instant Lockscreen. Per Tastenkürzel. Gepriesen sei der Herr. Wer war das? Wer hat das geschickt? Quasrich.
Hast du einen Twitter-Account, Quasrich?
Das war das goldene Bit dieser Sendung.
Control, Shift, Eject, Lockt.
Den Screen.
Wenn man Screen Locking eingeschaltet hat. Das heißt, man kann Screen Locking auch so einschalten, dass es sich nie automatisch einschaltet, aber man kann es dann immer einschalten?
Das wär dann auch...
Bei mir wacht er einfach nur wieder auf.
Du musst halt in Security-Preferences sagen, require password immediately after sleep or screen saver begins. Und dann funktioniert es.
Bei mir ist es immediately sein.
Bei mir ist es nämlich nicht immediately, sondern bei mir ist es erst nach ein paar Minuten.
Ach so, aber das ist ja... Weil ich will nicht... Warte mal. Ach so, wenn man irgendwas, was nicht immediate hat, dann funktioniert das gar nicht.
Also bei mir wird einfach nur das Display dunkel. Du hast auch gar keinen Eject-Tast auf deinem... Doch, hat er einen Eject-Tast?
Was ist denn ein Eject-Tast auf dem MacBook Air? Was willst du denn ejecten?
Na ja, es gibt hier auch Dinge, man mountet ja Sachen. Also unter anderem auch CDs.
Ich will auch nochmal. Doch, geht doch. Und dann macht er halt auf, weil du es halt erst nach vier...
Aber er fragt mich jetzt nicht nach dem Passwort.
Nee, weil du halt sagst, hier Passwort erst nach vier Stunden.
Ja, aber ich hätte halt gerne etwas, wo er nicht... Achso, Require Pass... Ah, okay, alles klar. Nee, warte mal, ich hab dich falsch verstanden. Dann probier ich das jetzt mal aus. Ah, Rock o Mart.
Also, ey, nach diesem Shortcut...
Jetzt lassen wir uns hier mal von Quasrich, lassen wir uns mal hier schön mal seinen Twitter-Account geben. Los, bitte hier einmal Twitter-Account.
Kann man ja vielleicht schon. Und wir haben gleich geflettert. Ach, das ist ja geil.
Ging schon mit System 7... mit System 8.1.
Nein, also wirklich. Das ist ja der Hater-Sinnung. Jetzt macht der uns nass.
Ich würde sagen, wir stellen jetzt den Podcast auch ein. Unsere Tarnung ist aufgefroren.
Darf ich da wieder nach Windows 7 puten?
Jahrelang haben wir uns als DMAG-Experten ausgeben können. Und jetzt kamen hier diese guten Plagg Wiki-Chat-Hinies und haben uns die Maske vom Gesicht gerissen.
Wie großartig.
Von wegen hier Dr. Mac und so.
Also, ich muss dich ja leider enttäuschen, Huckel, aber hier hat gerade jemand einen Screenshot gemacht, dass man auch in Launchbar einzelne Programme einstellen kann, eine Liste editieren kann, bei denen die Clipboard-Historie ignoriert wird.
Das ist aber auch noch nicht die ganze Zeit immer drin.
Bei Launchbar 1?
Nein, bei Launchbar, ich weiß nicht, bei welcher Version.
Ach so, diese Clipboard-Historie kann man wieder später, aber es hat mich vollkommen verwirrt, diese Clipboard-Historie.
Wieso denn?
Weiß ich nicht mehr, hat mich total verwirrt.
Also die Clipboard-Historie ist voll super, was mich immer gestört hat, ist dieses Feature.
Ist das nicht das, wenn ich dann zweimal Copy mache, dass das dann sich irgendwie, ist das nicht so mit Copy, Copy hat dann ein anderes Verhältnis oder sowas?
Nee, da kannst du deine Clipboard-Einträge Mergen, aber das habe ich Disabled, weil das ist total...
Genau, das macht mich nämlich wahnsinnig, weil manchmal muss man bei Mac OS 10 zweimal Copy machen, damit er überhaupt kopiert.
Das ist total ätzend, das habe ich ausgedacht.
Okay, dann werde ich das vielleicht mal einschalten. Deutschpan ist ja auch so ein Programm, wenn man sich da erstmal drin wohlfühlt, dann will man da jetzt nicht permanent dran rumzoppeln und dann entgehen einem natürlich auch manche Features. So, Clipboard, History. Oh, ist sogar eingeschaltet bei mir.
Ja, das hab ich. Also, die Merge, die man da halt aus...
Genau, Merge hab ich ausgeschaltet. Preserve, History Across Restart. Aha, und dann Ignore Applications. Na ja, ist doch drin.
Also, das muss man editieren, wusste ich aber gar nicht. Aber... Also, mir ist so, als wäre das noch nicht.
Action-Item?
Wahrscheinlich, dass das als Action auftaucht, dass da sagen, oben eintippen kannst, Copy und dann macht er einen Copy.
Kannst halt... Also, der nimmt es halt nur in die History auf, wenn du Copy und Paste gemacht hast. Nee, das macht er auch beim Copying. Na, ich hab sie mir auf Apfel Alt V gelegt, dann kommt sie. Ausgeklappt und du kannst dann auch mit Tastentippen kompliten lassen.
Achso, dafür gibt es dann einen Okay-Alst-Gleich-Versteher.
Und das ist halt echt cool. Du kannst mit Cursor-Keys da durch navigieren oder du kannst aber auch anfangen zu tippen und dann filtert er in der History gleich die Items raus. Das ist echt...
Das ist das, was du immer suchst, dass es ohne Formatierung kopiert wird.
Genau, da kannst du einstellen, ob er die Formatierungsinformation beibehalten soll. Oder ob er immer Plain Text, Copy & Paste macht.
Für jede Aktion, für jedes Kopien, unabhängig von der History, oder nur wie er es in die History übernimmt.
Wie, was, was, was, was?
Ich hab's ausgemacht, weil ich das schon so original...
Schalt das mal ein, wenn das...
Dein Herzschröpmacher piept.
Das glaub ich jetzt noch nicht ganz, aber man weiß ja nie, ne?
Hat er jetzt schon seinen Twitter-Namen gepastet, der Quaserich?
Weiß ich nicht.
Vielleicht ist das sein Twitter-Name.
Also irgendwie hat er das noch nicht rausgerückt hier.
Aha, der sagt einem aber auch, dass das... Okay, ne, also das hat er jetzt nicht gemacht.
Quasrich, gibt's tatsächlich als Twitter-Namen. Nimm das mal in die Simple Note auf.
Und der ist aus Österreich, Tirol, und hat noch nie getwittert und followt uns.
Der hat noch nie getwittert? Hat der gerade erzeugt den Account oder was?
Also er followt schon 20 Leute.
Ich würde sagen, der ist nicht neu.
Okay, das heißt, wir tippen jetzt mal alle...
Aber der Trissa, der followt den Fanboy, der followt Meta-Ebene, der followt iPhone-Block, der...
Der ist also der Fanboy TN. Okay, dann logge ich mich jetzt mal bei Flatter ein und flatter da mal rüber.
Privacy live bei Mobile Max.
Ja, du bist geoutet.
Hier gibt es auch so People Finder Seiten und so weiter.
Tragen wir ihn gleich ein.
Nach Ausziehen hier, dem zeigen wir uns den Besserwisser aus dem Chat.
Hat doch bestimmt bei den Fanboys gehört.
Das hat er nur auf Twitter gelesen.
Jetzt kriegt er hier Flatter... Pending, wieso denn? Hier, nimm das Geld!
Naja, weil er das jetzt erst mal klemen muss.
Ja, weiss ich. Versteh ich.
So ist das.
Jetzt muss er aber mal Twittern hier, Quassrich.
Genau.
Also, da ernern davon bin ich ja. Du meinst, das kann man mal machen, wenn er noch nichts getweetet hat, ist die Chance auch gering, dass er dir die Timeline vollquatscht.
Nö, wir followen hier mal Leute und dann weiß ich nicht mehr, wer sie sind, und dann followst du hier wieder.
Sie haben sogar das Flattern von Twitter-Usern verbessert bei Flattern. Das stelle ich gerade fest. Das ist ein weiteres für meine Feature-Rekrits. Aber da steht ein Tweet.
Hier steht, in der Zeitbar steht, ein Tweet hätte er gesendet, aber unten in der Timeline steht Hasn't tweeted yet.
Ein Rätsel.
Der ist total unsichtbar.
It's magic.
It's magic. Also das war wirklich Danke, danke, danke. Das war wirklich der großartigste Shortcut, den ich seit langer Zeit gelernt, lernen durfte, ja.
Ich zeige mir das nochmal.
Hat nicht... MS Pro war nochmal so stolz drauf, dass er dir eine Tastenkombination beigebracht hatte.
Können wir das alle bitte kurz einsprechen? Vielleicht ist das ja was für das nächste Intro.
Control Shift Eject.
Ist das jetzt denn ein neuer Name? Ist ja so ähnlich, als ob man so ein Windows-Podcast Alt-F4 nennen würde.
Also das ist auch übrigens, Control Shift Eject ist übrigens auch der Shortcut, wenn man den Mac aus dem Sleep aufklappt und es kommt nicht der Login-Screen. Wenn man dann Control Shift Eject so ein paar Mal betätigt, dann irgendwann...
Ach du meinst, das ist so ein Reanimationstaste?
Ja, das ist auch ein Reanimationstaste. Also es hat auch heilende Kräfte.
Das ist aber auch wirklich so eine Krankheit, ne? Ja, das ist fassungslos von deinem Gerät. Das verstehe ich überhaupt nicht, was da passiert.
Gut, dass ich nicht der Einzige...
Vielleicht könnten wir einfach nur diese heilige Tasten-Kombination nicht.
Ja, also...
Das ist so ein bisschen, das.
Komplettiert alles, das ist so ein bisschen so, das beantwortet alle Fragen. Herrlich.
Jetzt können wir auch keine neuen Themen mehr aufbringen. Ist euch das bewusst? Damit ist die Sendung gelaufen. Das war's jetzt. Weil wir haben jetzt auch schon wieder genug durch. Das krieg ich schon wieder alles nicht exportiert, geschwärbelt und hochgeladen, noch gepostet, noch veröffentlicht, aber ich nehme mir trotzdem Mühe.
Guck mal, da gibt's auch schon die passenden Icons dazu.
Herrlich. Das ist aber kein Shift. Das ist ein Command, Control Eject.
Der Kenner hat's gleich am Geschmack erkannt.
Und wieso soll man das nicht drücken? Was passiert dann?
Na ja, dann mach mal.
Was ist denn? Ach nee, es passiert. Was hat denn Shift? Das ist einfach Pfeil nach oben.
Oh Gott, jetzt hat sich Tim total geoutet.
Er weiß nicht, wie die Shift-Taste aussieht.
Nee, mir war jetzt grad nicht klar.
Das ist die Großmacht-Taste, Tim.
Großmacht-Taste?
Ja, ich mach dann mal groß. Großmacht-Taste.
Also Großmacht-Taste hab ich tatsächlich auch noch nicht gehört.
Es gab irgendeine Tastenkombination, mit der konnte man das MacBook schlafen legen, aber der USB-Port hat noch Strom geliefert. Die hat MS-Pro die irgendwann mal verraten. Weiß ich, dass er sehr stolz drauf war, dass du das noch nicht kanntest.
Komand, Control Eject ist doch Sleep, oder? Täuschig mich.
So, und so installierten wir uns MacDefender.
Nee, da wollte er irgendwie einen Restart machen.
Hat er gefragt?
Nein, Command Eject ist Sleep.
was?
Command Alt Sleep.
Es gibt keine Sleep-Tasse.
Nein, wir haben nichts geraucht.
Und das ist was? Das geht gleich in den Sleep. Ja, das ist der Sleep.
Genau. Das heißt, hier unten ist auch so ein kleines Epi-Zentrum.
Was heißt, wenn man noch länger umprobiert, dann kriegt man noch diverse andere Kombinationen hin. Wachrütteln wäre ganz gut. So ein Kommen wieder hoch. Guck mal jetzt zum Beispiel. Jetzt habe ich ihn zwar schlafen gelegt, aber jetzt wird er nicht wach werden. Gerade bei dem R, das ist das Gerät, das mit dem Instant On verkauft wird.
Hier muss ich manchmal länger warten.
Aber mit Tilt, es gab so ein CD- und DVD-Brennprogramm namens Disco. Und das hatte auf den Rechnern mit Motion Blablabla, bei diesem Motion Sensor hier, ob der bewegt wird, wurde so eine Warnung eingeblendet, wenn man beim Brennen einer CD zu sehr am Mac gerüttelt hat. So, hey, du brennst gerade noch eine CD, das könnte hier echt nach hinten losgehen. Und dann hat er auch einen Tilt irgendwann angezeigt. Und das konnte sogar, das war echt cool. Also es war eines der überflüssigsten Programme überhaupt, aber es sah dabei sehr, sehr schick aus. Es hat während man eine CD gebrannt hat, konnte man in den Optionen einschalten, dass Rauch aufsteigt aus dem Fenster. Und das war echt gut animierter Rauch. Ich habe leider keinen CD-Brenner mehr drin. Man brennt ja auch eigentlich nie was.
Ja, wir haben ja doch noch mal dieses Thema Programme, die die Sensoren und sonstigen Teile ganz gut netzen. Ich bin ja hier, glaube ich, so einem Tweet so einer Werbekampagne aufgesessen. Ich sage es ja nur sehr ungern.
Immer mehr schockierende Wahrheiten über Tim Prittler zum Leben werden, dringend in die Oberfläche.
Das bestürzt mich immer sehr, wenn ich irgendwie so etwas auf den Leim gehe. Aber da ich es jetzt schon mal getan habe...
Du hast jetzt sehr günstig Viagra gekauft.
Ich kann jetzt noch länger. So dürfte man die Sendung nicht nennen. Durch den iTunes Store nicht mehr durch. Es gab hier irgendwie so ein Tweet von irgendeinem Vogel. Ich weiß jetzt immer noch nicht, was so die Realität ist. Vielleicht stimmt das auch alles. Aber hier, egal, auch wenn es Werbung ist, thisguyhasmymacbook.tumblr.com Ja, das sah mir gerade schon sehr nach Werbung aus. Ja, das ist irgendwie so...
Weil das sieht irgendwie erstaunlich ähnlich dem Design dieser Webseite zu dem Programm, was genau das gleiche, was heißt, hidden ab. Das ist doch quasi die identische Farbe, oder? Wenn mich nicht alles tauscht.
Ach, da ist noch.
Aber jetzt gibt es hier Updates. The Oakland Police has acquired my MacBook last night and I picked it up this morning. Arrested. Oakland Police Officer just called me to let me know that they arrested the guy in my photos. Also ist das jetzt wahr oder nicht? Follow, jetzt muss ich mal schauen. Also wenn das stimmt, ist die Story wirklich hart. Aber ich finde diese Fotos, die sind irgendwie zu gut. Ich meine, man setzt sich doch nicht. Ich meine.
Also die Fotos finde ich, sehen jetzt nicht total unorthentisch aus.
Aber ich meine, der hat seinen MacBook im Auto aufgeklappt und dann...
Ja, also das ist tatsächlich etwas merkwürdig. Aber die anderen, finde ich, sehen jetzt irgendwie...
Also im Bett, während er sich da gerade irgendwie Dinge im Internet anschaut.
Naja, das ist jetzt so ein Zustand, der jetzt nicht exorbitant selten auftritt.
Aber ich meine, das kann doch jetzt gar keine Werbeaktion mehr sein. Was meint denn der Chat? Der Chat meint, es ist alles. Der Chat meint, ja, es ist so passiert und es ist Werbung. Also sozusagen beides.
Die haben sich ihr MacBook klauen lassen?
Schauen wir mal, was Joshua Kaufmann irgendwie hier...
Auf dem Konto halt.
So, jetzt flettern wir den...
I'm here to pick up my MacBook. Ich meine, jetzt hat er hier sogar Fotos. Und jetzt hat er noch sein Foursquare-Check-In von ich bin beim Ogden Police Department. Wie auch immer. Also diese Programme, die sich so... Also die sind schon ein bisschen creepy so. Machen Screenshots, schalten deine Kamera ein, fotografieren dich sozusagen beim Arbeiten. Ich frag mich jetzt so ein bisschen, wenn einem das Ding geklaut wird, muss man dann erst diesen Modus von außen einschalten? Also muss das Ding quasi einmal so vom Internet gesagt bekommen, so ab jetzt bist du geklaut?
Oder ist der pre-enabled?
Oder schicken sie schon mal von dir die ganze Zeit Fotos, wie du so wichsend vor deinem MacBook sitzt, irgendwie Youporn-schauend auf den Server, für den Fall, dass du der Dieb bist. Das ist mir noch nicht so ganz klar, welchen Level an Privatsphäre so eine Software dann noch übrig lässt. Aber ich meine, der Typ zieht das hier irgendwie total durch. Was hat denn der überhaupt für eine Vita? Ja, er hat ja auch eine eigene Webseite. Also sieht irgendwie alles nicht so gefaked aus.
Noch mal zwischendurch kurz zur Vollständigkeit. Es gab nie eine Netscape 5 Version.
Im Internet gab es nicht. Aber ich weiß auf jeden Fall, dass ich mal Webseiten gesehen habe, die so eine 5er Version haben wollten vom Browser. Also die nicht von Internet Explorer gesprochen haben. Hidden heißt das Ding. Das ist glaube ich nicht die einzige Software. Ich weiß nicht mehr so ganz genau, wie die anderen heißen.
Ja, da gibt es massenhaft von.
Aber ich meine, in dem Moment, wo die Scheiße wegkommt, ist das auch wirklich so das Ding.
Das MacBook hat er ja trotzdem nicht wieder.
Deswegen will ich ja immer noch ein MacBook haben, das auch so 3G hat. Weil dann ist einfach so, ich meine, so hängt das einfach davon ab, dass du irgendwie W-Lan hast. Und in dem Moment, wo es 3G hat, könnte es einfach jederzeit, wo es das erste Mal wieder aufgeklappt wird, einfach sofort aktiv werden.
Remote Wipe für Notebooks, iCloud. Find my Mac mit Remote Wipe und bitte alles.
Das ist doch ein No-Prainer.
Das ist doch ein No-Prainer, das ist doch schon drin.
Ja, ich meine mit der neuen Vollverschlüsselung ist das jetzt auch problemlos machbar.
Und du kannst ja bei Lion, wenn du den installierst und die Full-Disk-Encryption... Und wenn du das so in der Situation anmachst, dann bietet er dir die Möglichkeit an, den Key, den Revocation Key, bei Apple zu speichern, ne?
Ja, stimmt.
Das heißt, du könntest den da ablegen und dann hätten sie den und könnten dann eben genau... Also, ich predikte mal, dass es Find My Mac und Remote Vibe für Mac und so auch mit Lion und so weiter, mit iCloud geben wird.
Vielleicht wird das sogar noch besser. Vielleicht ist es so, dass derjenige, der es geklaut hat, nicht auf deine Daten zugreifen kann, du aber schon.
Was ist das denn? Hier kommen schon Fotos rein.
Mit Control Shift Eject.
Ich finde Bum-Zack-Return besser.
Das ist im Prinzip dasselbe, ne?
Außer das Bum-Zack-Return, was in der Aktion versetzt worden ist gegen Control Shift Eject. Ja, eher das Gegenteil davon.
Das ist für dich sozusagen ein Zeichen des Aufbruchs. Also du gehst jetzt schnell essen, machst Control Shift Eject und gehst vom Rechner und hast gelockt. Und dann beginnt für dich ein neuer Lebensabschnitt.
Und man geht guten Gewissens und offenen Auges und frohen Gemüts in die Zukunft.
Apropos, wir gehen in die Zukunft. Lass uns mal hier ein Ende machen und setzen. Ich will diese Sendung ja auch noch veröffentlichen. Ich habe noch ein bisschen Schlafnacht zu holen und noch viel zu tun morgen. Und auch weitere Podcasts sollen ja auch irgendwann mal durchgehört werden. Insofern machen wir hier mal ein Ende. Es war wieder lang genug. Wollen wir artig und brav Tschüss sagen?
Wir schließen die Sendung mit dem Flaschenkonzert. In H-Moll. Also auf Wiederschauen. Die WWDC-Hymne sozusagen.
Ich sag, Schatz, das stimmt so nicht, aber die Idee ist gut.